THE ROLL.
ALLEN.
ARCHULETA.
ATKINS.
BATES [inaudible]
BELL.
GORGEOUS.
BRADFORD.
COUNTY AT ALL [inaudible]
CHAIN [inaudible]
DALLY [inaudible]
DODD.
THERE ARE SO [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
LASER GONZALEZ [inaudible]
GROW [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HILL.
HUESO -- TADO [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONNING [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN PORTANTINO [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
STONE.
NUMBER.
BY CASKEY.
WINNER [inaudible]
WILK.
COLLEAGUES A QUORUM IS PRESENT
[inaudible]
WOULD.
THE MEMBERS IN OUR GUESTS BE ON
THE RAIL AND IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE RISE.
WE WILL BE LEAD IN PRAYER THIS
MORNING FIRE CHAPLAIN SISTER
MICHELLE GORMAN.
AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING WE WILL BE LED IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO OUR FLAG
A BY SENATOR HUESO.
LET US CENTER SERVES IN GOD'S
PRESENCE AGAIN.
I HAVE A LITTLE FUN POEM THIS
MORNING.
FROM THE SEVENTEENTH CENTURY I
HOPE NOBODY FUNDS THAT DILUTES A
WEE BIT SACRILEGIOUS.
IT'S CALLED FIRST HE LOOKED
CONFUSED.
I COULD NOT LIE ANYMORE.
SO I STARTED TO CALL MY DOG GOD.
FIRST HE LOOKED CONFUSED.
THEN HE STARTED SMILING.
AND THEN HE EVEN DANCED.
I KEPT ****.
AND NOW HE DOESN'T EVEN BITES.
I AM WONDERING IF THIS MUCH WORK
ON PEOPLE.
SO GRACIOUS GOD.
HELP US TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE SPARK
OF DIVINITY IN EVERYONE WE MEET
TODAY.
ESPECIALLY THOSE WHOM WE'VE BEEN
CONDITIONS TO DISMISS OUR TO
MARGINALIZE.
WE ASK THIS IN YOUR NAME AMEN.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
OF YEAH.
SEN ONE NATION UNDER --
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY YEAH
[inaudible]
ALL
COULD HAVE YOUR ATTENTION
PLEASE WE ARE READY TO BEGIN
TODAY SESSION SO IF ALL MEMBERS
WOULD TAKE THEIR SEATS SENATOR
MCGUIRE -- HAS A PRESENTATION
UNDER MOTIONS -- EXCUSE ME UNDER
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR SO
COLLEAGUES IF WE COULD.
THE WHAT IF WE COULD HAVE YOUR
ATTENTION PLEASE.
SENATOR MCGUIRE UNDER PRIVILEGES
OF THE FLOOR IT IS ALL YOURS
THANK YOU SO MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT IN MEMBERS MEMBERS THE
AYE AYE IS AN EXCITING DAY WE
HAVE A STATE.
CHAMPION AMONG US THIS MORNING
AND ONE ONE OF THE BEST
WRESTLERS IN THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA AND HER NAME IS
ADRIANA LOPEZ.
SHE'S FROM UPPER LAKE HIGH
SCHOOL IN LAKE COUNTY CALIFORNIA
AND NOT ONLY IS SHE THE TOP
FEMALE WRESTLER IN HER WEIGHT
CLASS IN THE GOLDEN STATE.
ADRIANA IS A TRAILBLAZER SHE
MADE SCHOOL ISTORY BY BEING THE
FIRST STUDENT TO EVER HOLD A
STATE TITLE ACROSS ANY SPORT
MADAM PRESIDENT.
ANY SUPPORT FROM UPPER LAKE HIGH
SCHOOL USE ME SENATOR.
COULD WE PLEASE HAVE QUIET IN
THE HOUSE.
AND SHE IS THE FIRST EVER
STUDENT TO HOLD A STATE TITLE
FROM THE ENTIRE COUNTY OF LAKE
SHE'S FIERCE SHE IS A WICKED
SMART.
SHE CRUSHES THE COMPETITION AND
SHE HAS MADE CALIFORNIA PROUD WE
COULDN'T BE MORE EXCITED TO
WELCOME MISS LOPEZ OF THE SENATE
AND HER MOM AND POPS IN BY THE
WAY.
JOE HER POPS HE IS ALSO THE
UPPER LAKE WRESTLING COACH
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN I ASK YOU
TO WELCOME THE CHAMPION TO THESE
OTHER CHAMBERS.
USING YOUR LOUD AND PROUD VOICE
IT'S GET MISS LOPEZ A ROUND OF
APPLAUSE HER AMAZING
ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
HEY WHO EXAMPLE OF WHAT SMALL
BUT MY HE MEANS CONGRATULATIONS
.
THANK YOU TITLE
[inaudible]
NINE EXCELLENT EXCELLENT.
THANK YOU AGAIN AND
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU MAKE OUR STATE VERY PROUD.
AND WITH THAT COLLEAGUES SENATOR
BATES FOR WHAT PURPOSE A PURPOSE
TO CALL A CAUCUS REPUBLICAN IN
THE COX LOUNGE.
REPUBLICAN CAUCUS IN THE COX
LOUNGE
REPUBLICAN CAUCUS HAS
CONCLUDED WE ARE READY TO RE
COMMANDS ARE.
FLOOR SESSION WE WILL GO BACK TO
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR IF THERE
ARE ANY.
ARE THERE ANY FURTHER PRIVILEGES
OF THE FLOOR [inaudible]
SHE NON.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ MESSAGES FROM THE
ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED READ.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED.
UNDER MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES.
PURSUANT TO SENATE RULE TWENTY
NINE POINT TEN THE FOLLOWING
BILLS ARE REFERRED TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE.
CERTAIN FILE ITEM SEVENTY EIGHT
AB.
SEVENTEEN FIFTY TWO MEMBERS
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL ADOPT
THE AUTHORS AMENDMENTS ACROSS
THE DESK ON FRIDAY JUNE TWENTY
FIRST TWENTY NINETEEN THESE
AMENDMENTS WILL BE ADOPTED
PUBLISHED AND RETURNED TO
COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE SENATE
JOURNALS FOR JUNE SEVENTEENTH
THROUGH THE TWENTIETH TWENTY
NINETEEN WILL BE APPROVED AS
CORRECTED BY THE MINUTE CLERK.
UNDER FURTHER ITEMS.
MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES
SENATOR -- BURKE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE
REMOVE A. B. NINE FIVE SIX OF A
SPECIAL CONSENT CALENDAR THANK
YOU.
THE CLERK WILL NOTE SENATOR DODD
UNDER MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES YES I REQUEST THAT FILE
ITEM -- NUMBER NINETY TWO SP TWO
THIRTY TO BE REMOVED FROM
CONSENT PLACED ON THIRD READING.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THERE WILL BE
THE ORDER AND ALSO -- THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE
PLACE UP FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE OH
THREE ABC -- TEN SEVENTY NINE
REMOVE IT FROM THE CONSECUTIVE.
SO NOTED BY THE CLERK THERE WILL
BE THE ORDER.
ANY FURTHER NOTICES -- MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES SEEING
NONE COLLEAGUES WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO CONSIDERATION OF THE
DAILY FILE.
UNDER SECOND READING MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
A SYMBOL FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT WITH
A WOMEN'S TWELVE NINETY ONE AT
THE MOMENT SIX NINE WITH THE
MOVEMENT SIX SEVENTY ONE WITH
THE MEMBERS. FOR THIRTY WITH THE
MOMENT SEVENTEEN SIXTY THREE AT
THE MOMENT SECOND READING WILL
BE DEEMED TO COMPLETE.
MOVING ONTO UNFINISHED BUSINESS.
COLLEAGUES WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO
FILE ITEM.
TWENTY THREE FILE ITEM.
TWENTY THREE WE PREPARED TO
PROCEED ON FILE ITEM
.
TWENTY THREE SENATOR MITCHELL
THE FLOOR IS YOURS COLLEAGUES IF
WE COULD PLEASE TAKE OUR SEATS.
IF WE COULD PLEASE TAKE OUR
SEATS.
AND OUR GIVE OUR ATTENTION. TO
SENATOR MITCHELL [inaudible]
MISTER SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL ONE OH
THREE BY THE CAMINO BHAJAN
FISCAL REVIEW AN ACCOLADE THE
STATE PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT MAKING
PREPARATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT MERELY BILL RELATED
BUDGET.
SENATOR MITCHELL THE FLOOR IS
YOURS I APPRECIATE YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM PRESIDENT AND GOOD MORNING.
SENATE BILL ONE OH THREE
PROVIDES LEGISLATIVE
RATIFICATION OF A MEMORANDUM OF
UNDERSTANDING BETWEEN THE STATE
AND BARGAINING BARGAINING UNIT
SIX REPRESENTING CORRECTIONAL
PEACE OFFICERS.
THE MO YOU WILL BE IN EFFECT FOR
ONE YEAR COLLEAGUES FROM JULY
THIRD TWENTY NINETEEN TO JULY
SECOND.
TWENTY TWENTY I WILL IMPACT
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND FULL TIME EQUIVALENT
EMPLOYEES THIS BILL PROVIDES A
3% GENERAL SALARY INCREASE ON
JULY ONE AND MAKES VARIOUS
COMPENSATION ADJUSTMENTS.
I'M ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL.
SENATOR NIELSEN UNDER DEBATE AND
DISCUSSION. FOR SURE SO THAT A
PEASANT LADIES AND GENTLEMAN THE
SENATE.
I AM URGING A NO VOTE ON OUR
UNRIVALED RATHER ON THIS.
I HAVE VOTED AGAINST SOME OF
THESE IN YEARS PAST.
IN A VOTED ON A MANY.
PROBABLY SOME TEN AT LEAST OF
THESE OVER THE YEARS.
I THINK I CAN SAFELY SAY I KNOW
MORE ABOUT THE BEAT THAT THESE
INDIVIDUALS THESE MEN AND WOMEN
WALK.
THAN ANYBODY AROUND HERE.
I HAVE WORKED WITH THEM.
THROUGHOUT MY LIFE.
AND I'VE BEEN WITH THEM IN THE
PRISONS.
WHERE THEY WORK?
I'VE BEEN IN THIS PROMISE
[inaudible]
WITH THEM.
WITH IN MAY.
TWO OR ACTING UP.
AND HEARINGS THAT WE WERE
CONDUCTING.
IT IS A VERY DEPRESSING
ENVIRONMENT.
VERY LITTLE IN THEIR DAY'S WORK
[inaudible]
IS POSITIVE.
AND THE MOST IMPORTANT QUALITY
IN TRADE.
OF THESE INDIVIDUALS IS AN
ABILITY NOT TO TAKE IT HOME.
I LEARNED TO IDENTIFY IN MY OWN
EMPLOYEES AT THE BOARD OF PRISON
TERMS ONE ONE OF THE EMPLOYEES
WILL START TO TAKE THINGS HOME.
AND WOULD SIT DOWN AND HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT THAT.
THE THINGS THEY SEE.
AND HAVE TO DO.
ARE NEVER PLEASANT.
AND THERE ARE FEW BRIGHT LIGHTS.
OF INDIVIDUALS WHO [inaudible]
REALLY SHINE [inaudible]
SUCCESSFULLY [inaudible]
REHABILITATE.
THEIR LIVES ARE AT RISK.
AT EVERY MOMENT.
IF THERE IS ANY SPECIAL
CONSIDERATION FOR THIS CLASS.
THE STATE EMPLOYEES.
I WOULD ARGUE THEY MORE THAN
DESERVE IT.
AND I URGE.
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR NIELSEN
SENATOR WILL.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB ONE OH
THREE WHICH RATIFIES A
MEMORANDUM OF UNDERSTANDING
BETWEEN THE CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONAL PEACE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION.
AND THE STATE.
MEMBERS CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS
PROVIDE ESSENTIAL SERVICE TO OUR
STATE WE EXPECT THEM TO
REHABILITATE THOSE.
IT'S FAMILIES COMMUNITY AND
OTHER PUBLIC SERVANTS WERE NOT
ABLE TO DO.
THEY HAVE AN EXTREMELY DIFFICULT
EMOTIONALLY DEMANDING JOB WERE
THEY NOT ONLY HAVE TO PROTECT
OTHERS BUT CONSTANTLY WORRY
ABOUT THEIR OWN SAFETY.
AND WE ARE JUST BEGINNING TO
UNDERSTAND THE MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES THAT RESULT FROM THE
STRESS CORRECTION OFFICERS IN
JUROR IN THE WORKPLACE.
A REPORT RELEASED IN OCTOBER OF
LAST YEAR.
BY UC BERKELEY FOUND THAT QUOTE
CALIFORNIA'S CORRECTIONAL
OFFICERS ARE REGULARLY EXPOSED
TO DRAMATIC ADVANCE THE MAKE THE
MORE LIKELY TO GRAPPLE WITH
DEPRESSION.
PTSD AND SUICIDAL THOUGHTS.
FURTHERMORE THE REPORT FOUND
THAT MORE THAN HALF THE
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS REPORT
THAT VIOLENT INCIDENTS ARE
REGULAR OCCURRENCE IN THE
WORKPLACE.
WITH ALMOST 30%.
REPORTED BEING SERIOUSLY INJURED
85% REPORTED SEEING SOMEONE
SERIOUSLY INJURED OR KILLED. 50%
OF OFFICERS SAY THEY RARELY FEEL
SAFE AT WORK AND OFFICERS WHO
DON'T FEEL SAFE ARE MORE LIKELY
TO REPORT HEADACHES.
DIGESTIVE ISSUES HIGH BLOOD
PRESSURE DIABETES AND HEART
DISEASE.
MORE THAN ONE THIRD OF OFFICERS
REPORT THAT SOMEONE THEIR LIFE'S.
HAT HAS TOLD THEM THAT THEY
BECOME ANXIOUS OR DEPRESSED THAT
SINCE STARTING TO WORK IN THE
CORRECTIONAL FACILITY. 28% OFTEN
FEEL FILLED HAVE FEELINGS OF
DEPRESSION DEPRESSION OR
HOPELESSNESS AND 38% HAVE LESS
INTEREST OR PLEASURE IN DOING
THINGS. ONE IN THREE HAS
EXPERIENCE AT LEAST ONE SYMPTOM
OF PTSD. 10% CORRECTION OFFICERS
HAVE THOUGHT ABOUT KILLING
THEMSELVES WITH THE RAPING
HIGHER FOR RETIRED CORRECTIONAL
OFFICERS AT ONE IN.
SEVEN OF THOSE WHO SAY THEY
THOUGHT ABOUT SUICIDE 31% REPORT
THINKING ABOUT HOW OFTEN AND HOW
FOR THE PAST YEAR MORE THAN
SEVEN AND TEN HAVEN'T TOLD
ANYONE.
MANY THAT MANY ARE SUFFERING IN
SILENCE.
MEMBERS I KNOW THERE'S BEEN
MEDIA.
ARTICLES ABOUT THIS IN ARE YOU
SAYING THAT THERE IS NO
JUSTIFICATION FOR THE PAY OR
BENEFITS.
BUT I SAY WHAT MORE
JUSTIFICATION DO YOU NEED AND
THEN THE THE STUDY THAT CAME OUT
BY UC BERKELEY LAST OCTOBER AND
I RESPECTFULLY.
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE FOR SB ONE
OF THREE YOU SENATOR WILK
SENATOR DOLLY.
THE MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS I
ALSO.
BUT TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB ONE
OH THREE I HAPPEN TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR SIXTEEN YEARS AS
A COUNTY SUPERVISOR.
AND LASSEN COUNTY SERVE WERE.
A LOT OF MY CONSTITUENTS WERE
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS AT HIGH
DESERT STATE PRISON.
AND I WILL JUST HAVE FRIENDS
PERSONAL FAMILY FRIENDS AT WORK --
AT THE CENTERS AND ALL THE
STATISTICS THAT -- THE CENTER
WILL GO JUST STATED ARE ACTUALLY
FACTUAL THINGS THAT HAPPEN TO
THESE FOLKS THEY THEY CAN IT'S
VERY HARD FOR THEM TO DISCONNECT
FROM TEIR JOB.
THEY COME HOME AND THE THE THIS
THIS IS DEFINITELY JUSTIFIED --
COMPENSATION FOR THEM AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS THE BILL.
THANK YOU SENATOR DOLLY IS THERE
ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
SENATOR ARCHULETA.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I TO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL.
ONE OH THREE I HAD THE OCCASION
TO VISIT -- ONE OF OUR STATE
PRISONS IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
AND I FOUND THE MEN AND WOMEN
WHO ARE WORKING THERE WITH
CONDITIONS THAT I'VE NEVER BEEN
ABLE TO SEE BEFORE.
THE RESPONSIBILITY THEY HAVE BUT
THEY ALSO FELT IT WAS A
PRIVILEGE TO SERVE AND REPRESENT.
BUT IT THE RESPONSIBILITY AND
THEY TOOK IT SERIOUSLY.
THEY KNEW THAT THEY HAD TO DEAL
WITH THE INMATES.
IN A CALM PRODUCTIVE WAY THEY
KNEW THAT THEY HAD TO DO A JOB
BECAUSE THEY HAD TO GET HOME.
AND THEY ALSO KNEW THAT THE
INMATES ALSO WERE HUMAN BEINGS
THAT OBVIOUSLY WERE SUFFERING
FROM -- INCARCERATION FOR
WHATEVER ACTION BUT THEIR HEART
THE PASSION FOR THE JOB WAS
THERE.
BUT I WAS ALSO CONCERNED ABOUT
THEIR SAFETY EVERY SINGLE DAY
THEY PUT THEIR LIVES IN THEIR
HANDS.
SO WHEN WE'RE ABLE TO ALLOW THEM
TO REPRESENT US TO PROTECT US WE
MUST ALL THROUGH. TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THEIR SERVICE SO WITH THAT I
ASKED FOR THE AYE BOAT.
THANK YOU CENTER ARCHULETA.
SENATOR TO RUSSELL.
YES I ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS -- OF NOT ONLY THE REASONS
THAT HAVE BEEN SAID BY MY
COLLEAGUES BUT ALSO BECAUSE IN
MY VISITS -- TO TWO OF THE
PRISONS I ALSO FOUND OF MEN AND
WOMEN THERE WHO WERE INVOLVED
AND PROGRAMS. TO HELP OUR
SISTERS AND BROTHERS WHO WERE IN
PRISON. TO LOOK FORWARD TO A
FUTURE LIFE THAT THEY WEREN'T
STUCK IN A SITUATION -- BUT
RATHER THEY COULD ACTUALLY LOOK
FORWARD TO HOW DO THEY GET THE
SKILLS TO COME OUT -- WHEN THEY
CAME OUT?
AND WORK WITH THEM WORK WITH
THEIR FAMILIES AND HI -- I FEEL
VERY STRONGLY ABOUT THAT PART OF
THE WORK THAT THEY DO EVERY
SINGLE DAY SO I ASKED THE FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR ROGER ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SEEING AND HEARING NONE SENATOR
MITCHELL YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THE THE
THE THOUGHT FULL DEBATE AND AND
COMPASSION EXHIBITED BY MANY OF
MY COLLEAGUES IN THE FOR FOR
EIGHT CHALLENGING WORK
ENVIRONMENT -- AS THE DAUGHTER
OF A RETIRED CDC OUR WARDEN -- I
CERTAINLY CAN ATTEST TO MANY OF
THE CHALLENGES THAT THEY'VE
EXPERIENCED -- AS MY COLLEAGUES
ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE AISLE
TALKED ABOUT AND SO AS WE ARE
FOCUSED ON THE WORK CONDITIONS --
FOR MEMBERS OF UNIT SIX WE
SHOULD ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT THOSE
ARE THE SAME CONDITIONS UNDER
WHICH MANY CALIFORNIANS ARE
LIVING AND SO WE SHOULD WORK.
COLLABORATIVELY TO MAKE SURE
THAT EVERYONE'S EXPERIENCE IN A
CD R. CD SEE OUR FACILITY IS --
FOCUS HUMANELY.
OFF I'M PROUD TO HEAR THE ABOUT
THE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT SB WON
ALL THREE AND AGAIN ENCOURAGE AN
AYE VOTE.
ALL DEBATE HAVING SEIZED MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
BY BILL [inaudible]
I PORGES [inaudible]
I BRADFORD.
BY KELLY AT ALL [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
HI DOLLY [inaudible]
I DOT.
HI THERE ALSO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
BY GLAZER [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
GONZALEZ [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
I HERTZBERG.
BY HILL AYE HUESO.
BY -- TITLE.
BY JACKSON HI BY [inaudible]
JONES.
BY LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL.
AYE MONNING.
BY MORE LOCK.
NO [inaudible]
WELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
BY PAN AYE PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO.
AYE SKINNER [inaudible]
BY STERN [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
HI NUMBER.
THE PILOT COUNTY [inaudible]
I WINNER.
NO WILK.
HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ONE MORE TIME ALLEN
[inaudible]
STERN.
VICE THIRTY FOUR KNOWS FOR
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
MOVING ON NOW TO FILE ITEM
[inaudible]
TWENTY FOUR SENATOR MITCHELL.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL NINETY SIX BY THE
COMMITTEE A BUDGET FISCAL REVIEW
AN ACT WILLING TO TAXATION AND
CLEARING THEIR THROATS DEFECT
MERELY.
SENATOR MITCHELL.
COLLEAGUES SENATE BILL NINETY
SIX RECASTS THE SURCHARGE THE
FUN CRITICAL. NINE ONE ONE
SERVICES.
THE CURRENT SYSTEM IS OUTDATED.
AS IT'S ORIGINS DATE BACK TO THE
EARLY SEVENTIES.
AND AS WE S
SASTERS THE NINE ONE ONE
SYSTEM CAN QUICKLY GET
OVERWHELMED IN THE EVENT.
OF AN EMERGENCY.
A LIFE THREATENING EMERGENCY.
THE REVENUES BUT THIS BILL WILL
DIRECT WHAT'S FUN THE NINE ONE
ONE SYSTEM INCLUDING NEXT
GENERATION.
NINE ONE ONE INTERFACE IS NEEDED
TO DELIVER IT NINE ONE ONE VOICE
AND DATA INFORMATION FROM THE
NINE ONE ONE CALLER TO THE
EMERGENCY RESPONDER.
AN INTERFACE IS NEEDED TO SEND
INFORMATION ALERTS AND WARNINGS.
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
ESTIMATES THAT A FULL YEAR'S
REVENUE COLLECTION UNDER THIS
RESTRICTION FEE WOULD GENERATE
APPROXIMATELY ONE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
BASED ON A RATE OF THIRTY FOUR
CENTS PER LINE.
THE SURCHARGE WILL BE DETERMINED
BY A NUMBER OF FACTORS INCLUDING
THE NUMBER OF ACCESS LINES THE
BALLOT IN THE STATE EMERGENCY
TELEPHONE NUMBER ACCOUNT.
AND PROJECT COSTS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WILL HELP AUTHORITY
TO APPROPRIATE.
THE LEGISLATURE WILL ALSO HAVE
OVERSIGHT OVER HOW THE REVENUES
WILL BE SPENT.
I ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER MITCHELL
SENATOR DOLLY.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I ALSO
STAND IS SUPPORT OF THIS
RESOLUTION I JUST WANT.
TO SHARE WITH YOU -- THIS BILL
SKEWS ME SB. NINETY SIX TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN SENATOR
NELSON I WITNESS THE FAILING OF
THE OROVILLE DAM SPILL WAY AND
WE EVACUATED OR BILL THE CITY OF
OR BILL.
UNDER EXTREME CIRCUMSTANCES
THERE WERE PROBLEMS WITH THIS
NINE ONE ONE SYSTEM THAT IS BEEN
IN PLACE SINCE THE NINETEEN
SEVENTIES.
LAST YEAR TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHTEEN WE HAD THE CAR FIRE IN
REDDING CALIFORNIA WHERE WE LOST
ELEVEN HUNDRED STRUCTURES AND
SEVEN LIVES.
WE HAD A FIRE TORNADO.
WE HAVE AYE FIVE RUNNING UP TO
THE MIDDLE OF THE CITY WE HAD TO
NINETY NINE WHICH RUNS.
ACROSS WAYS AND WE ARE TRYING TO
MOVE PEOPLE.
AROUND OUR CITY AND SAVE LIVES
AND WE HAD EXTREME CIRCUMSTANCES
OUR SYSTEM IS NOT BEEN UPDATED
IN FAILED US.
THEN ON TOP OF THAT.
WE HAD THE CAMP FIRE WHICH
HAPPENED FOUR MONTHS LATER.
AND WE LOST EIGHTY SEVEN LIVES
IN PARADISE.
I REPRESENT MIGUEL YEAH.
WHICH HAS.
ELEVEN A NINETY I DID REPRESENT
ME I IT'S IT'S NOT MY SENATE
DISTRICT.
BUT WHEN I FIRST REPRESENTED
THAT AREA I WENT OUT AND LOOKED
AND I KNEW THAT THERE WAS THERE
WAS A FIRE PRONE AREA AND THAT
THERE WAS SOME POINT THERE WOULD
BE A FIRE THERE SO WE PUT IN A
ACCESS ROAD.
ACTUALLY ADMITTED A BILL TO HAVE
AN X. CAPER OUT FROM THE
GALLERIA.
AND WITH THE FIRE FOR THE
CAMPFIRE CAME THROUGH.
MANY PEOPLE DID NOT KNOW THAT
THAT ROUTE WAS AVAILABLE AND
THEY WENT DOWN THE HILL INSTEAD
OF GOING UP THE HILL.
IF THIS SYSTEM WOULD HAVE BEEN
IN PLACE AND EXERCISE AND
WARNINGS I THINK.
THE OUTCOME WOULD HAVE BEEN
SOMEWHAT DIFFERENT.
I'M NOT GONNA SAY THAT THE NINE
ONE ONE SYSTEM.
IS GONNA.
EVERY TIME SAVE LIVES.
BUT THIS SYSTEM IS BROKEN AND ON
TOP OF THAT.
MANY PEOPLE THAT PAY INTO THE
SYSTEM IT WAS BASED OFF OF LAND
LINES.
THEN WE ADDED CELL PHONES.
AND THERE'S STILL PEOPLE WHO USE
THE SERVICE WHO DON'T PAY INTO
THE SERVICE [inaudible]
NOW.
I LOOK AT THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION.
THERE'S A LOT TO DEBATE WHETHER
SHOULD BE.
IT IN YOU KNOW TAXES AND FEES
AND I LOOK AT WHAT GOVERNMENT'S
PRIMARY FUNCTIONS ARE
[inaudible] FOR ME.
THE GOVERNMENT SHOULD DO THINGS.
THAT THE PEOPLE CAN'T DO ON
THEIR OWN. TO COLLECTIVELY WE
PUT IN WATER SYSTEM SO WE CAN
ALL HAVE WATER SO WILL PAY A
LITTLE BIT.
COLLECTIVELY WE BUILD
INFRASTRUCTURE ROADS SCHOOLS WE
PROTECT OUR NATION.
THOSE ARE THINGS THE GOVERNMENT
IS SUPPOSED TO DO.
AND I BELIEVE THAT PUBLIC SAFETY
IS ONE OF THOSE FIRST ISSUES
THAT WE SHOULD BE TALKING ABOUT.
pPERFECT NOW.
BUT WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
ALONG THE WAY.
CHECK IN AND HELP.
CRAFTED IN A WAY THAT WILL MAKE
OUR COMMUNITIES MORE SAFE.
AND A SYSTEM THAT WORKS I WANT
TO ALSO PAINT A PICTURE I
REPRESENT A DISTRICT.
MY ASSEMBLY DISTRICT PART OF MY
SENATE DISTRICT IS WAS TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND SQUARE MILES.
MY WIFE AND I TRAVEL THOSE ROADS.
AND NOT EVERYWHERE DO YOU HAVE
CELL SERVICE OUT THERE.
WE CAME UPON AN ACCIDENT.
WHERE LIVES WERE THREATENED WE
HAD A DRIVE A FEW MILES BEFORE
WE GOT CELL SERVICE?
AND WHEN WE CALLED.
NINE ONE ONE THEY DON'T KNOW
WHERE YOU'RE AT SO IT CAN BE YOU
CAN BE LASSEN COUNTY AND THE
CALL MAY GO TO MODOC COUNTY.
THEN HAS TO BE RE ROUTED FROM
THE C. H. P.. TO THE CALL CENTER
TO FIGURE OUT WHERE THE HECK
YOU'RE OUT OUT THERE.
THEN AFTER TWENTY MINUTES OF
GETTING RE ROUTED AND TELLING
THEM WE HAVE A EMERGENCY.
THEN WE GO BACK AND TELL THE
PEOPLE WE HAVE HELP ON THE WAY
WHICH IN THIS CASE IS.
OURS IN SOME CASES FOR UP TO AN
HOUR TO GET FIRST RESPONDERS
THERE.
SO I THINK THIS IS A GREAT PIECE
OF LEGISLATION I AM VERY HAPPY
TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT IT I DON'T
I DON'T KNOW WHERE MARK GILL OUR
DUTY IS IF HE'S IN HERE I WANT
TO SAY I KEPT MY PROMISE TO YOU
I THE BILL DID NOT GET. TO THE
ASSEMBLY LAST YEAR AND I TOLD
HIM OUT TO THE CAR FIRE I WOULD
VOTE FOR THIS BILL.
I WANT TO KEEP MY WORD I'M GONNA
VOTE FOR THIS BILL TODAY I THINK
IT'S A GOOD BILL I THINK IT
NEEDS A LITTLE BIT OF WORK --
BUT I THINK THIS IS WHAT
GOVERNMENT IS SUPPOSED TO DO.
COLLECTIVELY WE ARE SUPPOSED TO
GET EVERYBODY THE TABLE.
EVERYBODY'S USING THE SERVICE
SHOULD PAY A LITTLE BIT.
AND WE SHOULD PUT TOGETHER A
SYSTEM THAT ALLOWS US TO KEEP
OUR COMMUNITY SAFE.
NOW THIS CLOSE WITH THIS I HAVE
A NINE YEAR OLD DAUGHTER ROSLIN
WHO.
CANNOT HAVE A CELLPHONE UNTIL
SHE'S.
THIRTEEN THAT'S THE RULE IN THE
DELI HOUSE.
BUT WHAT SHE HAS THAT PHONE.
I WANT HER TO BE ABLE TO DIAL
911- IF SHE NEEDS ANYTHING IF
SHE'S BEEN ASSAULTED IF SHE'S
WHATEVER IT MAY BE AND IT.
THE RESPONSE TO BE QUICK TO HER.
SO I URGE AN AYE VOTE I THINK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK ON
THIS BILL AND I WANT TO THANK
THOSE -- REGGIE AND AND MARK
YOUR DUTY AND THE GOVERNOR --
FOR AND THEN THE REST OF PEOPLE
THAT WORK ON THIS BILL IS A
TOUGH BILL.
BUT IT'S THE RIGHT THING TO DO
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR JACKSON.
HI TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE AND APPRECIATE THE THE
WISE WORDS OF OUR NEWEST MEMBER
ONE OF OUR NEWEST MEMBERS THE
GOOD SENATOR FROM.
I BELIEVE IT'S BIEBER -- AS THE
THE VICE CHAIR IN IS THE FORMER
CHAIR OF THE JOINT aMITTEE
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT I TO SHARE
THE BELIEVE.
THE ONE OF THE FUNDAMENTAL
RESPONSIBILITIES OF GOVERNMENT
IS THE SAFETY OF ITS PEOPLE.
AND SO TO ME THIS IS NOT A
PARTISAN BILL.
THIS IS NOT AN IDEOLOGICAL BILL.
THIS IS A PRAGMATIC BILL THAT
WILL GO A LONG WAY TO ASSISTING
AND HELPING.
MEET THAT PROMISE OF GOVERNMENT
TO KEEP OURS OUR COMMUNITY SAFE.
LIKE THE GOOD SENATOR FROM
BIEBER I HAVE A STORY ABOUT THE
INADEQUACIES OF OUR CURRENT NINE
ONE ONE SYSTEM EVEN IN OUR NON
RURAL AREA.
WHERE THE PINKING THAT WENT ON
MISDIRECTED THE MOST CRITICAL
EMT SERVICES THAT HAD THEY BEEN
MORE ACCURATE WOULD HAVE SAVED
THE LIFE?
IN MY COMMUNITY WHICH WAS LOST
AS A RESULT.
COLLEAGUES THIS SYSTEM IS FORTY
YEARS OLD.
AND FOR THOSE OF US WHO CAN
REMEMBER BACK FORTY YEARS OLD WE
HAD DIAL TELEPHONES.
WE DIDN'T KNOW WHAT THE INTERNET
WAS I HAD NO IDEA WHAT A
GIGABYTE WAS.
WHAT IS CELL PHONE WAS THAT'S
FORTY YEARS AGO THERE WAS NO
ANALOG THERE WAS NO DIGITAL?
THERE WAS NOTHING LIKE WHAT WE
HAVE TODAY AND HERE THE STATE
THAT INVENTS THE FUTURE.
THAT IS THE HOME OF THE ADVANCED
TECHNOLOGIES.
THE FACT THAT WE ARE ONLY ONE OF
THREE STATES LEFT IN THE ENTIRE
UNITED STATES.
THAT HAS FAILED TO UPGRADE TO
THE SYSTEM.
IS FRANKLY APPALLING.
AND WHETHER YOU THINK IT THIS IS
TOO MUCH OR TOO LITTLE.
THE FACT IS WHAT IS A LIFE WORTH
TO YOU.
BECAUSE WHEN WE HAVE FIRES WHEN
WE HAVE EMERGENCIES WE NEED TO
GET WHAT WE CALL REDUNDANCY WE
NEED EVERY WAY POSSIBLE TO LET
PEOPLE KNOW THAT THEY ARE IN
DANGER.
THIS IS ONE OF THE MOST ADVANCED
WAYS WE CAN DO THAT WE WOULD BE
REMISS IN OUR RESPONSIBILITIES
IF WE DIDN'T DO THAT.
AND SO THERE'S AN ARGUMENT ABOUT
WHETHER SHE WE TAX PEOPLE OR
SHOULD WE TAKE A ONE TIME FEE.
I ASK YOU THIS WHAT IS A LIFE
WORTH TO YOU.
WHAT IS YOUR HOME WORTH TO YOU?
WHAT IS YOUR?
LARGE STOCK WORK DO YOU FOR YOUR
PETS AND THE ANSWER IS.
IT'S WORTH FOR MORE THAN ARGUING
OVER WHETHER THEY SHOULD BE A
ONE TIME.
THE INFLUX OF MONEY IN FACT IT
CAN'T BE BECAUSE HE SYSTEM WILL
CONTINUE TO BE REVISED AS
TECHNOLOGIES IMPROVE WE NEED TO
WE WANT WE DESERVE.
THE MOST ADVANCED WARNING
SYSTEMS IN A STATE WHERE RIGHT
NOW WE ARE UNDER FIRE ALERT THIS
VERY MINUTE AS WE SPEAK.
AND AS THE GOOD SENATOR FROM
BEEPER AND OTHER COLLEAGUES OF
MINE HAVE THE EXPERIENCE THESE
WILDFIRES AND HOW QUICKLY THEY
MOVE.
ANYTHING AND EVERYTHING WE CAN
DO TO GET PEOPLE OUT OF DANGER
AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE IT IS OUR
RESPONSIBILITY AND SO I STAND IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS EFFORT.
WHETHER IT'S FR WILDFIRES
WHETHER IT IS FOR A CHILD AT
HOME DURING A BREAK IN ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT THE SYSTEM WILL
DO IT WILL ALLOW THOSE WHO
EITHER CAN'T GET PHONE SERVICE.
OR ARE UNABLE TO USE THE PHONE
TO BE ABLE TO TAXED OR VIDEO
THEIR CONCERNS IF THERE IS A A
PREDATOR IN ONE'S HOME A FEW
YEARS SUBJECT OF A BURGLARY YOU
DON'T WANT TO GET ON THE PHONE
AND CALL.
WITH THIS SYSTEM YOU'LL BE ABLE
TO TEXT THE EMERGENCY SYSTEM
YOU'LL BE ABLE TO SEND A VIDEO
WE'LL KNOW WHERE YOU ARE WHETHER
YOU'RE IN THE MIDDLE OF A RURAL
AREA -- OR IN THE MIDDLE OF
DOWNTOWN SANTA BARBARA OR OTHER
PLACES WE WILL BE ABLE TO HELP.
AND THAT IS OUR RESPONSIBILITY
FOR GOVERNMENT.
REGARDLESS OF PARTY REGARDLESS
OF IDEOLOGY THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
MEASURE AND I RESPECTFULLY URGE
AN AYE VOTE ON IT.
THANK YOU SENATOR BATES
[inaudible]
HELP CENTER.
I'M SORRY.
MISTER PRESIDENT I DIDN'T
RECOGNIZE MY NAME.
GOT A LITTLE HEARING PROBLEM
TODAY.
BUT I DO RESPECTFULLY ROUTE RISE
IN OPPOSITION OB PROBABLY BETTER
SAY IT SAID I WILL NOT BE ABLE
TO SUPPORT.
OUR THE MEASURE TODAY I DO NOT
DISAGREE THAT WE NEED TO A NEW
MODERNIZE NINE ONE ONE SYSTEM.
ARE CERTAINLY ONE THAT INVOLVES
WITH CHANGES IN TECHNOLOGY BUT
THIS PROPOSAL REMAINS FLAWED AND
WE DEALT WITH THAT LAST YEAR ON
SOME OF THE SAME ISSUES I'M
GOING TO RAISE.
IT'S A BLANK CHECK IT LACKS A
CLEAR PLAN AND IT LACKS
ACCOUNTABILITY AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY BASED ON THE
PREVIOUS DISCUSSION FROM MY
FELLOW MEMBERS -- THERE IS NO NO
ASSURANCE THAT THIS IS GOING TO
HAPPEN IN THE NEAR TERM.
THE CURRENT TAX THAT WE HAVE
GENERATES APPROXIMATELY SEVENTY
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY AND
THAT'S LEVY DON AS WE KNOW BOTH
LAND LINES AND WIRELESS ACCOUNTS.
THIS PROPOSAL INCREASES AND
BROADENS THE NINE ONE ONE TAX
BASED UPON THE NUMBER OF ACCESS
LINES.
I RECOGNIZE THE NEED TO BROADEN
THE TAX AS A MATTER OF FAIRNESS
AND STABILITY.
UNFORTUNATELY THIS PROPOSAL
ALLOWS THE ADMINISTRATION AND I
WANT TO EMPHASIZE THIS MEMBERS
NOT US NOT LEGISLATIVE MEMBERS
NOT OUR REPRESENTATIVES OF THOSE
PEOPLE THAT WE HAVE PROMISED TO
ENSURE THEIR SAFETY.
IT REMAINS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION TO INCREASE THE
TAX RATE TO GENERATE A TOTAL OF
ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY ON GOING.
THE UPPER CAP OF EIGHTY CENTS
WOULD GENERATE MORE THAN TWICE
AS MUCH REVENUE AS YES THINKS
LET ME EMPHASIZE THAT THINKS IT
NEEDS.
ARE WHAT IS THE TOTAL COSTS
NEEDED FOR NINE ONE ONE UPDATE.
ON MEETING WITH THE GOVERNOR
LAST YEAR THAT THAT QUESTION WAS
BOB POSED -- TO YES THEY COULD
NOT ANSWER THE QUESTION WHAT
WILL THE COST OF THE ANNUAL
OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE NEED
GOVERNOR BROWN ASKED DIRECTLY TO
THE OYSTER AFTER.
THERE WAS NOT AN ANSWER WHEN
WILL THE PROJECT BE COMPLETED
AND WE HAVE JUST HEARD HOW
URGENT HOW URGENT THAT IS NEEDED
BECAUSE WE ARE FACING MAJOR
CLIMATE CHANGES THAT DRIVEN SOME
OF THESE HORRIBLE CATASTROPHES.
WE DON'T HAVE AN ANSWER TO THAT
AND WE LOOK AT OUR OTHER OUR
TECHNOLOGY SYSTEMS HERE IN OUR
STATEGOVERNMENT AW THEY HAVE
NOT -- MATT WHAT WAS ORIGINALLY
INTENDED WHAT IF THIS SYSTEM
DOES NOT THERE HAVE BEEN NO
CLEAR ANSWERS AND WE DESERVE
THESE ANSWERS NOW IF WE ARE TO
ENSURE TO ENSURE THE SAFETY.
OF THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN SO
DEVASTATED -- AND POPE TENSELY
THAT CAN HAPPEN IN THE NEAR
FUTURE SO WE NEED IMMEDIATE
ANSWERS.
THE SAD TRUTH IS THAT OUR STATE
GOVERNMENT HOUSE SUPPORT TRACK
RECORD WHEN IT COMES TO
DELIVERING PROJECTS HAD BEEN
PROMISED TO EACH AND EVERYONE OF
US.
IN A VARIETY OF OUR COMMITTEES
STATE REPUBLICAN SENATE
REPUBLICANS DID PROPOSE THAT THE
GENERAL FUND BE USED TO PAY JUST
FOR THE DEVELOPMENT TO GET IT
GOING TO BUILD OUT THE NEW ONE
ONE SYSTEM LET'S ET IT GOING.
THIS WOULD EXPEDITE THE PROJECT
LAST YEAR WE HAD TEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR EACH EACH MARINE
MUSEUM.
THIS YEAR WE HAVE MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS FOR DOG PARKS AND SUMMER
CAMPS SURELY SURELY WE HAVE
MONEY.
OUR TO FIND A NEW NINE ONE ONE
SYSTEM BUILD OUT IMMEDIATELY
ONCE THE SYSTEM IS OPERATIONAL
DOWN WE WOULD BE ABLE TO WORK
OUT WHAT THE NEEDS WOULD BE FROM
ABROAD IN TAX STRUCTURE THAT I
THINK WE WOULD ALL BE VERY VERY
SUPPORTIVE UP.
BECAUSE WE DO NEED TO FUND THE
OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE AND
ANY UPGRADES THAT WOULD BE
NEEDED.
THEREFORE WE WOULD REQUEST THAT
A LEGISLATIVE APPROVAL AT LEAST
BE REQUIRED FOR FUTURE RATE
INCREASES AND TO KNOW OUR WHAT
IS WORKING IN TERMS OF THE
DEVELOPMENT WHAT IS NOT WORKING.
WE WOULD ALSO REQUEST THAT THERE
BE TRANSPARENCY AND REPORTING TO
THE LEGISLATURE TO ENSURE
ACCOUNTABILITY ON THE PART OF
THE ADMINISTRATION.
THIS WOULD PROVIDE FOR SOME
ASSURANCE OF THE PROJECT GETS
BUILT GETS BUILT QUICKLY IN THAT
IT ACTUALLY WORKS -- YES ONCE A
BLANK CHECK THE LEGISLATURE GETS
NO CERTAINTY THAT THE PROJECT
GETS BUILT OR THAT IT WORKS AND
WE HAVE THE EXPERIENCE THAT AND
I DON'T WANT TO MENTION THE
DIFFERENCE.
BOB IBM'S THAT WE'VE HAD WITH
SOME OF OUR AGENCIES BUT IT'S A
FACT SO SHOULD WE ENSURE THAT
THIS IS NOT GOING TO FALL.
ON THE SAME PROBLEM WE'RE ALSO
BEING ASKED TO PROVIDE A MASSIVE
TAX INCREASE IN PERPETUITY
WITHOUT KNOWING WHAT THE COSTS
OF OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE
WILL BE.
I DO BELIEVE WE CAN DO BETTER WE
TRIED LAST YEAR I WOULD LIKE TO
REMIND US ALL THAT -- YES IS HAD
ONE WHOLE YEAR TO COME OUT WITH
AT LEAST WHAT THEY WERE GONNA
PUT IN OUR IF P. AS THEY WENT
OUT TO BID ON THIS PROJECT.
AND I HAVING SERVED AT THE
COUNTY GOVERNMENT THIS WOULD
NEVER HAPPEN IN YOUR COUNTY
GOVERNMENTS THAT SOMEONE COULD
TAKE A YEAR.
BE REJECTED THE FIRST YEAR SAY
COME BACK WITH THE SPECIFICS
WE'LL GET IT ROLLING THEY NEVER
DID THAT SO I WILL NOT BE ABLE
TO SUPPORT THIS TODAY.
AND CERTAINLY I AM VERY VERY
CONCERNED WITH US SAFETY WE HAD
TERRIBLE FIRES AN ORANGE COUNTY
WE HAVE A REVERSE NINE ONE ONE
SYSTEM.
THAT ARE COUNTY IMPLEMENTED AND
IT WORKS VERY WELL PERHAPS
THAT'S THE ANSWER IN THE SHORT
TERM AND I WOULD SUGGEST THAT.
BUT IN THE LONG TERM WE NEED
BETTER ANSWERS ON THIS WE NEED A
SYSTEM THAT SAW A LITTLE LIKE.
CLASSE AND I'M NOT SURE THIS IS
GOING TO GET US THERE SO TODAY I
WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO SUPPORT
THIS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR BATES SENATOR
GROVE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
I TO JOIN MY COLLEGE FOR MY
COLLEAGUE FROM ORANGE COUNTY TO
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
AND I KNOW THERE ARE A LOT OF
EMOTIONS AROUND THIS PARTICULAR
PIECE OF LEGISLATION BECAUSE
THERE WERE LIVES LOST.
IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIAIN THE
CITY OF BE BURKE AND ALSO WHERE --
IN CITY SANTA BARBARA WHERE MY
OTHER COLLEAGUES SPOKE ABOUT
THIS.
IN -- SKIN THE YEARS CAN FIRE IN
MY DISTRICT WE HAD LIVES LOST --
SO I KNOW IT IS VERY IMPORTANT I
DO AGREE AND I THINK WE ALL
AGREE THAT IT'S AN ANTIQUATED
SYSTEM IN THAT IT NEEDS TO BE.
IMPROVED AND IT NEEDS TO BE.
DEVELOPED INTO A SYSTEM THAT
BENEFITS OUR CONSTITUENTS AND
PROVIDES OF A HIGHER QUALITY OF
SAFETY FOR CONSTITUENTS.
BUT YOU KNOW COLLEAGUES WE HAVE
A TWENTY TWO BILLION TWENTY TWO
BILLION DOLLAR SURPLUS -- THAT
CAN EASILY PAY FOR THIS AND I
THINK THAT THE ISSUE WAS THE
PAYMENT.
AND I THINK WHAT FRUSTRATES ME
THE MOST IS THAT WE TAKE AN
EMOTIONAL ISSUE WHETHER IT'S
THIS ISSUE THE DEVELOPMENT OF
STABILITY COMMUNITY WHATEVER THE
ISSUE IS.
IF IT'S A AN EMOTIONAL ISSUE
THEY THREW A TAX INCREASE OUR
TAX INCREASES ALWAYS PROPOSED ON
ONE OF THESE TYPES OF ISSUES
WHEN WE HAVE THE RESOURCES
WITHOUT IMPOSING ADDITIONAL
TAXES.
ON CALIFORNIANS TO BE ABLE TO
PAY FOR THIS STRUCTURE.
MY COLLEAGUE HAS MENTIONED
EARLIER IT WAS MENTIONED IN
ANOTHER IECE OF LEGISLATION A
COUPLE OF DAYS AGO THAT 53% OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA BELIEVES
THAT IT'S NOT AFFORDABLE TO
LEAVE HERE.
IF YOU TAKE THAT TO MILLENNIALS
AT 63% OF THE STATE CONTINUING
TO INCREASE TAXES DOES NOT MAKE
IT MORE AFFORDABLE TO LIVE HERE.
AND I SAW SOME PEOPLE WILL SAY
IT'S JUST EIGHTY CENTS BUT WHEN
YOU ADD EIGHTY CENTS ON TOP OF
ADDITIONAL GAS TAX INCREASES
THAT CONTINUALLY RISE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THERE'S OTHER WAYS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE CAN PROVIDE SAFETY AND
SERVICES TO OUR CONSTITUENTS SO
THAT WE HAVE AN UPDATED. NINE
ONE ONE SYSTEM THAT WORKS
WHETHER YOU LIVE IN A RURAL
COMMUNITY OR YOU LIVE IN
DOWNTOWN LOS ANGELES.
BUT THE IDEA TO INCREASE TAXES
ON THE ENTIRE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AGAIN.
AND WHEN WE HAVE THE RESOURCES
IN AS IN AS IN AS FAR AS A SLUSH
FUND BUT IN A RESERVE FOR TWENTY
TWO BILLION DOLLARS.
IN THE BUDGET BILL THAT WE
PASSED ON THURSDAY PASSED OUT
ALMOST THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN PET PROJECTS. TO A
LOT INDIVIDUALS DISTRICTS IT'S
JUST NOT THE WAY THAT WE AGREE
TO FINANCING SO THE OPPOSITION
IS NOT ABOUT.
THE OPPOSITION IS NOT ABOUT
HAVING A NINE ONE SYSTEM NINE
ONE ONE SYSTEM THAT WORKS THE
OPPOSITION IS ABOUT THE PAYMENT
AND HOW RESOURCES ARE REQUIRED
TO PAY FOR THIS SYSTEM.
SO I WOULD ENCOURAGE A NO VOTE
[inaudible]
SENATOR NIELSEN.
MADAM PRESIDENT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THE SENATE I RISE IN
SUPPORT BUT WITH A STRONG
MEASURE OF FRUSTRATION.
OVER THIS ISSUE.
I STOOD AGAINST IT LAST YEAR.
THEN RIGHTEOUS GOOD CONSCIENCE.
SOME OF THE SAME REASONS MY
ORANGE COUNTY CALLING JUST SPOKE.
LIKE MOST AGENCIES WHO COME TO
THE LEGISLATURE FOR MONEY.
THEY DON'T HAVE A PLAN.
THEY EXPECT US TO JUST INVEST IN
THEIR IDEA.
MAYBE IN EFFECT GIVING THEM.
A BLANK CHECK.
OVER THESE MANY MANY MONTHS I'VE.
ADMONISHED [inaudible]
AND REQUESTED [inaudible]
THE PLAN.
WELL FINALLY JUST THE OTHER DAY.
I GOT A VERBAL OUTLINE OF THE
PLAN.
NOT A DOCUMENT BETTER OF VERBAL
OUTLINE.
OF A PLAN.
THAT'S UNSATISFACTORY AND IS
TYPICAL OF THE ON RESPONSIVENESS
OF GOVERNMENTAL AGENCIES.
I HAVE TO WEIGH THAT THOUGH.
AGAINST THE NEED THAT WE HAVE
HERE.
THEN THIS IS UP FRONT AND
PERSONAL [inaudible] FOR FOLKS.
WE WERE IN THE MIDDLE OF THAT
FIRE.
I'M IN THE MIDDLE.
OF THE FIRE.
THE KNOW HUNDREDS WHO LOST THEIR
HOMES AND THEY'VE BEEN WORKING
EVER SINCE. TO ASSIST THE
COMMUNITIES PEARL. TO DIG OUT OF
THIS MESS.
ALSO.
I WAS A PART OF THE OROVILLE.
STILL WAY FAILURE AND I REMEMBER
VIVIDLY TALKING TO THE SHERIFF
ELEVEN O'CLOCK THAT NIGHT AS
THEY WERE ANTICIPATING THE SPILL
WAY FAILURE.
FEELING THE WEIGHT.
OF CEREMONIES BURDEN BECAUSE HE
SAID CHEN D. W. R. [inaudible]
ANOTHER AGENCY.
BUT SOMETIMES FAILS.
WE'RE NOT GIVING HIM CLEAR
SIGNALS OF THE NEEDS. FOR THE
IMMINENCE OF A BREAK.
I'M NOT SURE WHAT TO DO.
I SAID CORY HERE'S WHAT YOU DO
YOU DO WHAT YOU THINK IS RIGHT I
WILL NOT BE BEHIND YOU I WILL
NOT BE DECIDE YOU I'LL BE IN
FRONT OF YOU.
RUN INTERFERENCE.
AND HE MADE HIS DECISION A
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY EIGHT
THOUSAND PEOPLE [inaudible]
WERE EVACUATED.
AND YOU KNOW THE NINE ONE ONE
WAS A PART OF THAT.
THE COUPLE YEARS PRIOR.
IRONICALLY I WAS IN [inaudible]
CHICO.
AT A DINNER.
HONORING THE NINE ONE ONE OFFERS
OF RESPONDENTS [inaudible]
THE DISPATCHERS.
AND AS I ARRIVED IT WAS A KIND
OF A SPARSE CROWD IN THE DEPUTY
SHERIFF CAME UP THAT CENTER
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE A NOT MUCH
OF AN AUDIENCE HERE TONIGHT.
THERE'S BEEN A ACCIDENT ON I.
FIVE FOURTEEN CARS INVOLVED.
NOW THIS ACTION IT WAS ABOUT
FIVE MILES FROM A RANGE.
SO I'M VERY FAMILIAR WITH THE
AREA.
THOSE PEOPLE WHO ARE GOING TO BE
HONORED BY US THAT NIGHT.
HAD TO DEPART. TO DO THEIR
DUTIES.
THAT'S QUITE A MESS.
LIVES WERE LOST.
WE HAD ANOTHER INCIDENT IN THE
SCHOOL.
ABOUT TEN MILES FROM OUR PLACE
[inaudible]
THE SHOOTER.
AND THERE'S NO CELL.
ACCESS [inaudible]
AFTER.
WE WORK CHANCE TO ACCOMPLISH
SOME FOR THEM.
BUT THE POINT I MAKE.
AS WE REACH A DECISION HERE
TODAY.
THE YEARS HAVE PASSED.
THOUGH I AM NOT ALTOGETHER
COMFORTABLE AND HAPPY.
WITH THE LACK OF KNOWLEDGE THAT
WE HAVE BEEN PRESENTED WITH WHAT
WE ARE QUOTE BUYING INTO.
AND BY THE WAY THAT'S FLAVORED
BY THESE.
BILLION DOLLAR TECH PROJECTS
THAT THE STATE HAS INVESTED IN
FOR DECADES THAT HAVE.
GONE AWRY.
COST IS BILLIONS IN OVER RUNS.
AND NOT BEEN DONE ON TIME.
AND I THINK WE'VE BEEN ADVANTAGE
BY PROVIDERS.
IN THIS.
SCENARIO OVER THE YEARS.
COSTING TAXPAYERS A LOT MORE.
THAN IT SHOULD AND WE HAVE NOT
HAD GOOD OVERSIGHT THE AGENCIES
IN CHARGE OF OVERSIGHT.
NOW I THINK IT'S CALLED DO IT.
HAVE NOT DONE THE JOB.
BUT THAT BEGS THE ISSUE OF WHERE
WE'RE AT THIS MOMENT
[inaudible]
THIS MOMENT.
THERE IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US
TO UPGRADE THE SYSTEM I WISH I
KNEW EXACTLY HOW AND MORE ABOUT
IT.
UNFORTUNATELY I DON'T.
BUT AS LONG AS I'M PRIVILEGE TO
SERVE ON THE BUDGET COMMITTEE
AND AS VICE CHAIRMAN.
I WILL GUARANTEE THAT I WILL BE
A CONSCIENCE WATCHING OVER THIS
[inaudible] TO ENSURING.
THAT IT IS IMPLEMENTED FULLY
[inaudible]
ON TIME.
THEN ON BUDGET.
THIS IS TRULY A CRITICAL ISSUE
THIS IS A LIFE AND DEATH ISSUE
THIS IS MORE IMPORTANT THAN MANY
OTHER ISSUES WE WILL EVER
CONSIDER.
TODAY I URGE AN AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
SENATOR BORCHERS.
RESIDENT -- I WASN'T PLANNING ON
SPEAKING ON THIS ISSUE I THINK
YOU CAN CAN TELL MY COLLEAGUES
CAN TELL THERE'S A SPLIT.
AMONG SOME OF US.
BOB BUT I BELIEVE THERE'S A
FALSE CHOICE THAT HAS BEEN
DEVELOPED HERE.
THAT YOU EITHER CREATE THE TAX
TO SAVE LIVES OR YOU DON'T IN
LIVES WILL BE LOST.
THAT IS NOT ACCURATE IN MY IN MY
OPINION AND I BY THE WAY I
REPRESENT.
A LOT OF FOOT HILL MOUNTAIN
COMMUNITIES IN MY DISTRICT THIS
IS A CUTE LY.
OF CONCERN TO THE FOLKS I
REPRESENT -- IN THOSE BEYOND.
WHEN WE HAVE A TWENTY TWO
BILLION DOLLAR RESERVE?
AND IF OF BUDGET REFLECTS OUR
PRIORITIES.
THEN IT IS INCUMBENT UPON US TO
ALLOW THAT BUDGET TO REFLECT OUR
PRIORITIES IN THIS CERTAINLY IS
ONE OF THEM.
AND IT SHOULD BE A GENERAL FUND
APPROPRIATION TO FUND THIS
WORTHY CAUSE -- WE HEARD -- OF
FROM MY COLLEAGUE FROM US A
SANTA BARBARA WHO POSE THE
QUESTION WHAT IS A LIFE WORTH.
WELL I BELIEVE THAT.
ALL LIVES ARE WORTHY AND THEY
SHOULD BE -- PROTECTED THROUGH
GENERAL FUND APPROPRIATION FOR
THE AMOUNT OF WHATEVER IS NEEDED.
BUT THE IDEA THAT WE HAVE THIS
RESERVE WITH THIS SURPLUS UNDER
THESE UNIQUE CIRCUMSTANCES AND
HAVE THE WHERE WITH ALL TO MAKE
OUR INVESTMENT LIKE THIS.
I BELIEVE WE SHOULD.
AND THERE'S NO JUSTIFICATION FOR
DOING SO OUTSIDE OF THAT
APPROPRIATION PROCESS TAX NOT
NECESSARY UNDER THE
CIRCUMSTACES BUT THE NEED IS
COMPELLING.
IMMEDIATE AND NOW.
I JUST DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY WE
AREN'T -- TAPPING INTO THE
RESERVE TO FUND THIS WORTHWHILE
PROGRAM.
ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
SEEING AND HEARING NONE SENATOR
MITCHELL YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
YOU KNOW COLLEAGUES AS WE GO
THROUGH THE BUDGET BE ILL.
BUDGET BILL JUNIOR THE VERY
FIRST TRAILER BILLS THERE ARE
SOME ASPECTS OF THE BUDGET
DEVELOPMENT MAKING PROCESS THAT
ARE VERY COMPLEX THAT ARE MULTI
LAYERED.
THAT TAKE US ALL A MINUTE TO
WRAP OUR MINDS AROUND THE WE
RELY ON STAFF AND FINANCE AND
ELLIE EL. TO PROVIDE A SUPPORT
AND GUIDANCE.
COLLEAGUES I HAVE TO TELL YOU.
THIS ISN'T ONE OF THEM.
THIS IS NOT ROCKET SCIENCE.
THERE IS NO STATE IN THE UNION.
THAT PAYS FOR THEIR NINE ONE ONE
EMERGENCY SERVICES OUT OF
GENERAL FUND.
NOT.
ONE AND THEIR REASONS FOR THAT.
YOU ALL KNOW WILL BE HERE FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS THAT ARE GENERAL
FUND.
ALL THIS IS.
VERY FROM YEAR TO YEAR.
THIS YEAR WE HAVE THE PLEASURE
OF HAVING A TWENTY ONE BILLION
DOLLAR RESERVE.
AND FOR SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES
WHO ARE NOW SUGGESTING WE USE
THAT TO PAY FOR THIS.
IN BUDGET HEARING AS RECENT AS
YESTERDAY THE CLAIM WAS WE HAD
SAVED ENOUGH THE ONE THAT I'M
CONFUSED.
AND THERE ARE YEARS JUST THE
NINE YEARS I'VE SERVED IN THE
LEGISLATURE WE HAVE HUGE
DEFICITS.
THAT'S ONE VERY FOUNDATIONAL
BASIC REASON WHY NOT A SINGLE
STATE IN THE UNION USES THEIR
GENERAL FUND TO PAY FOR THEIR
NINE ONE ONE EMERGENCY SERVICES.
THIS IS NOT ROCKET SCIENCE.
WHEN WILL IT BE COMPLETED WELL
COLLEAGUES I REMEMBER VERY
CLEARLY STANDING ON THIS FLOOR?
VERY DISAPPOINTED IN THE OUTCOME
OF THAT DECISION A YEAR AGO OR
WE COULDN'T GET IT DONE.
SO I WOULD SUGGEST IF WE CAN'T
GET IT DONE AGAIN THIS YEAR.
THERE IS NO PROJECTION WHEN WE
WILL GET A COMPLETED.
YOU KNOW COLLEAGUES IT NEVER
OCCURS TO ANY OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS WERE EVER WE LIVE.
IN A FIRE PRONE AREA OR NOT IT
NEVER OCCURS TO A SINGLE
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT.
AND YOU COULD TAKE THIS TO THE
BANK.
THAT WHEN THEY PICK UP THEIR
PHONE AND CALL 911- THAT THERE
IS A CHANCE THAT IT MIGHT NOT
WORK.
IT NEVER OCCURS TO ANY
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT.
AND WHEN YOU HAVE HAD THE
OCCASION TO PICK UP THE PHONE
AND DIAL 911- IT'S BECAUSE YOU
ARE IN TROUBLE.
AND YOU NEED HELP.
AND IF WE'RE GOING TO SIT HERE
ON THIS FLOOR.
CAN HAVE THIS [inaudible]
SOPHOMORIC DEBATE.
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT IT IS OUR
DUTY AND RESPONSIBILITY TO STEP
UP AND DO WHAT'S RIGHT ON BEHALF
OF ELLIE EVERY CALIFORNIA
RESIDENT [inaudible]
I AM.
DEEPLY DISAPPOINTED IN THE
INTEGRITY OF THIS INSTITUTION
[inaudible]
ALABAMA.
A DOLLAR.
SEVENTY FIVE ARIZONA ARKANSAS
SIXTY FIVE CENTS DELAWARE SIXTY
CENTS GEORGIA A DOLLAR FIFTY
LOUISIANA A DOLLAR TWENTY FIVE
MISSISSIPPI A DOLLAR I WHAT A
DOLLAR.
THESE ARE THE STATE'S ACROSS OUR
COUNTRY WHO HAVE FEES THAT
EXCEED HE EIGHTY SET MAX THE
CALIFORNIA'S DISCUSSING IN THIS
BILL.
IT IS THE LEGISLATURE THAT WILL
HAVE THE POWER TO MAKE THE
APPROPRIATION DECISION REMEMBER.
AS THE LEGISLATURE WE LEGISLATE
AND WE APPROPRIATE.
AND IN THIS TRAILER BILL WE WILL
RETAIN OUR POWER AND AUTHORITY
IN A TIME TO ME. TO MAKE THE
APPROPRIATION DECISION UP TO A
MAXIMUM OF EIGHTY CENTS
[inaudible]
COLLEAGUES.
THIS IS NOT ROCKET SCIENCE IT IS
THE RESPONSIBLE STRATEGIC.
THOUGHT FULL THING TO DO TO MAKE
SURE THAT EVERY CALIFORNIA
RESIDENT.
MOST OF WHOM INCLUDING MYSELF NO
LONGER HAVE A LAND LINE.
HAVE ACCESS TO A SERVICE THAT
THEY BELIEVE WORKS WHEN THEY
NEED IT THE MALLS THE NINE ONE
ONE EMERGENCY LINE.
I ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE IN SB.
NINETY SIX THANK YOU SIR
MITCHELL ALL DEBATE HAVING
CEASED MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES.
NO BELL [inaudible]
HI.
BARGES.
NO BRADFORD.
HI KELLY HERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
DALLY [inaudible]
HI DODD.
HI THERE ARE SO.
I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER [inaudible]
HI GONZALEZ [inaudible]
BY GROWTH.
NO HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
BY HER TITLE [inaudible]
NO.
JACKSON.
I JONES [inaudible]
NO LEYVA.
BUY MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL.
BY MONEY.
HI MORE LOCKED [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
MORALE [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
I PAN.
BY PORTANTINO.
BY ROTH BY RUBIO.
BY SKINNER.
AYE STERN [inaudible]
BY STONE.
NO I'M BURKE [inaudible]
WHY COUNTY?
BY WIENER.
AYE WILK [inaudible]
NO.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
I'M BURKE.
I TWENTY NINE KNOWS TEN ON THE
URGENCY OUR EYES.
TWENTY NINE KNOWS TEN ON THE
MEASURE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
COLLEAGUES AT THIS POINT WE ARE
GOING TO JUMP OVER TO RETURN TO
OUR WE CAN RETURN TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS WERE WAITING FOR
SUPPLEMENTAL FILE -- TO BE
PREPARED SO WE ARE GOING TO
START WITH SENATOR UMBERG.
UNDER.
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY SENATOR UMBERG
THE FLOOR IS YOURS COLLEAGUES IF
WE COULD PLEASE GIVE ATTENTION.
TO SENATOR ON BURKE.
THANK YOU ADAM PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES -- TODAY -- YES THE
SENATE TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF
THE MOST VENERABLE.
QUAN THàNH WHO WAS AN AVID OF
THE BALL QUAN TEMPLE A FAMOUS
BUDDHIST TEMPLE IN SANTA ANA
CALIFORNIA.
HE WAS BORN IN. NINETEEN FIFTY
ONE AND BEEN TUNED VIETNAM IS
BIRTH NAME WAS ZONE THàNH TUNE.
USER NAME THE NINETEEN SIXTY
FOUR AS A SMART DYNAMIC NATURE.
HE MATURED QUICKLY AND BEGIN%
DEVOUT WORK IN BUDDHISM.
IN. NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX ONE
THàNH ESCAPE VIETNAM BY BOAT
TRANSITION TO AN INDONESIAN
REFUGEE CAM.
CAME TO RESETTLE THE UNITED
STATES.
AFTER COMING TO THE UNITED
STATES HE FOUNDED THE BALL QUAN.
WHO DOES CULTURAL CENTER AND
BECAME THE ABBOT OF THE BAO QUAN
TEMPLE IN ORANGE COUNTY?
THE TEMPLE IS A BEAUTIFUL PLACE
IN ORANGE COUNTY.
DURING THE PAST TWENTY THREE
YEARS IN ADDITION TO BEING THE
LEADER OF THE BUDDHIST COMMUNITY.
EVERY TUESDAY NO MATTER WEATHER
WAS RAINY.
WINDY.
OR OTHER INCLEMENT WEATHER HE
WOULD BE THE HOMELESSNESS CITY
SANTA ANA.
FEDERAL TAKE UPON THàNH WAS A
HUMANITARIAN A POET AN ART LEVEL.
AND ALSO AN INTERNATIONALLY
REVERED PHOTOGRAPHER.
IS A HOLY MAN AND EXCUSE ME
CENTER ON BURKE.
IF THERE ARE CONVERSATIONS THAT
ARE.
NEEDING TO TAKE PLACE PLEASE
TAKE THEM OUTSIDE THE HALL.
AND GIVE YOUR ATTENTION IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE TO SENATOR UMBERG
ON THIS.
ADJOURNED IN MEMORY.
AGAIN COLLEAGUES IF YOU WANNA
HAVE CONVERSATION PLEASE TAKE IT
EITHER TO THE BACK OF THE HALL
OR OUTSIDE THE WHOLE SO THAT
SENATOR UMBERG CAM PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZE.
THIS ADJOURNMENT MARIE THANK YOU
UP THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT --
MOST WEARABLE TECH ONE TON --
WILL BE REMEMBERED HE WAS
REVERED ORANGE COUNTY AND BEYOND
ORANGE COUNTY IN THE BLUES
COMMUNITY AND THE COMMUNITY AT
LARGE.
PASSED AWAY ON SUNDAY JUNE NINTH
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN AT THE BAO
QUAN TEMPLE.
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES I ASK YOU
JOIN IN -- MORALIZING IN IN
MEMORY OF THE MOST VULNERABLE
ONE TIME.
THANK YOU SENATOR UMBERG AND IF
YOU COULD PLEASE.
BRING FORWARD -- HIS NAME SO
THAT WE CAN PROPERLY MEMORIALIZE
HIM TO HIS FAMILY AND TO HIS
COMMUNITY.
OUR NEXT STOP SENATOR NIELSEN.
IN IN MEMORY PLEASE AND
COLLEAGUES AGAIN IF YOU COULD
GIVE YOUR ATTENTION TO SENATOR
NIELSEN.
MADAM PRESIDENT LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN OF THE SENATE.
THE MADAM PRESIDENT PERMISSION
TO DISPLAY A COUPLE OF HATS
[inaudible]
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
THESE -- HATS THAT REPRESENT.
THE BUSINESSES.
OF TWO MEN THE WE ARE JOINING AN
HONOR I'M ASKING YOU CHEN AN
HONOR.
RAFTER Vì RANCH FLYING SERVICE
MOST CROP DUSTING.
IN WILLIAMS CALIFORNIA.
AGRICULTURAL PILOTS HAVE OF THE
MOST HAZARDOUS JOBS [inaudible]
IN AVIATION.
AND THERE ARE NO EASY DAYS FOR
THESE INDIVIDUALS.
THEIR DAYS START EARLY SOMETIMES
A AND VERY LATE.
BUT THE VICISSITUDES OF THE
CIRCUMSTANCES UNDER WHICH THEY
ARE FLYING.
INCLUDING UNDER POWER LINES ALL
OF THE TIME.
ARE VERY RISKY.
HENCE THEIR SKILLS.
HAVE GOT TO BE.
ABSOLUTELY THE BEST [inaudible]
WE LOST [inaudible] TO OF THESE
PILOTS.
WHO ARE ALSO?
FARMERS.
I'VE WRITTEN IN I'VE NEVER FLOWN
BUT I'VE WRITTEN IN.
CROP DUSTERS.
OR AGRICULTURAL AIRCRAFT MANY
TIMES.
WHEN THEY WERE DOING THEIR JOBS?
A LOT OF WHICH IS FEEDING ACTUAL
FEEDING THE CROP RICE FOR
EXAMPLE.
A IT'S KIND OF A NERVOUS
[inaudible] TO THEM.
IT'S JUST LIKE SECOND NATURE
[inaudible]
SPIKE BUSINESS.
A FEW WEEKS AGO.
BIRD ALLEN ALL A AND BRIAN
JULIAN VANDYKE [inaudible]
WERE KILLED [inaudible]
THE COLLISION.
IN THE COURSE [inaudible]
OTHER DUTIES.
MAY FIFTEENTH THEY BOTH WENT UP
IN THERE [inaudible]
PLANES [inaudible]
EXPECTING A ROUTINE DAY FOR THEM.
IT DIDN'T IN THAT WAY SADLY
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN.
AND WE LOST BOTH OF THESE GOOD
MEN.
BIRD H<c.cyan> WAS BORN IN. NINETEEN</c>
SIXTY THE IRANIAN AND HOW H<c.cyan>.</c>
GREW UP IN OUR VOGON.
AND THEN MOVE TO WEAKEN IT.
WHAT THE WITH IN HIGH SCHOOL?
AND FATHERING FOLLOWING HIS
FATHER'S LEGACY.
THE BEGIN FARMING [inaudible]
AND FLYING.
DID A LOT OF FLYING FOR THEIR
OWN FAMILY OPERATION.
HIS BUSINESS WAS MOLDS CROP
DUSTING.
AND HE BECAME THE OWNER.
HE HAD A FAMILY TRADITION THAT
HE HAD TO KEEP UP.
AND THAT WAS FLYING A RED AND
WHITE [inaudible]
QUITE.
MANY OF THESE ARE YELLOW FOR
IDENTIFICATION REASONS AND
THEY'RE DISMAYED THAT WAY.
BUT HE'S CERTAINLY HAS
DISTINGUISHED HIMSELF WITH HIS
OWN UNIQUE [inaudible]
COLOR SELECTION.
HE THEN BECAME A CO OWNER OF THE
RED HILLS SALOON AND WE CAN AND
WITH HIS BEST FRIEND.
REENA SHRIVER.
WAS AN EASY GOING MAN.
HAD A GREAT SMILE [inaudible]
ALWAYS.
THERE TO HELP [inaudible]
HIS NEIGHBORS.
IS AN AVID HUNTER SPORTS FAN
[inaudible]
FISHING GOLFING SKIING AND BULL
RIDING WHICH SHE COULD DO AT THE
RED BLUFF ROUNDUP.
IN HIGH SCHOOL RODEOS WHICH SHE
HELPED PROMOTE.
ALONG WITH THE FLYING YOU.
FOLKS OF MARYSVILLE.
HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS BEST
FRIEND.
BILL OF LIFE COMPANION.
AND LONGTIME BUSINESS PARTNER
[inaudible]
RENEE SCHREIBER [inaudible]
HIS MOTHER.
A RAIN H<c.cyan> [inaudible]</c>
THE FAMILY.
MANY DEAR FRIENDS [inaudible]
BURKE.
WILL BE LONG MISSED.
HIS PARTNER AND I GUESS YOU
COULD TAKE COMFORT TO AGREES AND
THEY WENT TOGETHER DOING WHAT
THEY BOTH LOVED [inaudible]
BRIAN VANDYKE.
KIND OF A YOUR NAME TO MAKE
BECAUSE THAT'S MY WIFE'S MAIDEN
NAME THOUGH THERE WAS NO
CONNECTION TO THE FAMILY.
BUT THOSE FAMILIES BOTH.
INVOLVED IN AGRICULTURE.
HE WAS BORN IN NOVEMBER IN
NINETEEN FIFTY SIX TO DEAN AND
DONNA VANDYKE GREW UP IN
PLEASANT GROVE.
GRADUATED FROM EAST NECKLACE
HIGH SCHOOL.
GOOD FRIENDS WITH OUR
ASSEMBLYMAN JAMES GALLAGHER.
AND CHRIS TO ONE OR ONE OF MY
STAFF MEMBERS WAS BARELY A PART
OF THAT FAMILY.
HE WAS ACTIVE IN STUDENT
LEADERSHIP [inaudible]
IN ATHLETICS.
DURING HIS CAREER.
HE WENT TO CAL POLY SAN LUIS
OBISPO AND CHICO STATE.
THEN ALSO GRADUATED FROM THIS
YEAR A ACADEMY OF AERONAUTICS.
TO PREPARE HIM FOR HIS CAREER IN
AGRICULTURAL AVIATION.
HEWORKED IN HIS AND FARMING
BUSINESS.
AN AREA APPLICATION BUSINESS.
RAFTER Vì RANCH.
HE GAVE BACK TO THE COMMUNITY BY
SERVING ON THE SCHOOL BOARD
[inaudible]
PLEASANT GROVE.
SUPPORT OF THE FUTURE FARMERS OF
AMERICA BUYING LIVESTOCK.
THAT THEIR ANNUAL AUCTIONS.
PURCHASING THE FAIR ANIMALS THAT
WERE.
BROUGHT THERE BY THE STUDENTS.
HE I SURVIVED BY HIS BROTHERS
BOB GARY.
THE MOTHER OF HIS CHILDREN JENNY.
THOSE CHILDREN ARE CASEY BRANDON
SOUTH FORCED.
GRAND CHILDREN CRUZ CANNON
WESTON THE END.
BEAU HENRY AND TIME.
HIS GIRLFRIEND SANDY KING.
WITH A LOT OF OTHER FAMILY
MEMBERS [inaudible]
AND FRIENDS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT WE
ADJOURN.
IN THE HONOR TODAY OF BURTON
ALLEN HùI AND BRIAN JULIN
VANDYKE.
THANK YOU SENATOR NIELSEN AND
AGAIN IF YOU WOULD BRING THEIR
NAMES FORWARD SO THAT WE CAN --
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZE SOMEONE
PLEASE EXTEND.
THE SENATE'S CONDOLENCES TO
THEIR FAMILIES.
NEXT UP ARE UNDER GERMAN MEMORY
IS SENATOR STERN.
FLOOR IS YOURS SIR.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS -- I RISE TO JOURNEY
MEMORY TODAY OF MARY ELLEN
STROKE.
SHE WAS AN AUTHOR EDITOR AN
ADVOCATE FOR THE SANTA MONICA
MOUNTAINS.
HER WRITINGS IN THE LA TIMES AND
LOCAL OUT LET'S THROUGHOUT OUR
REGION WERE INSTRUMENTAL IN
BUILDING.
A PUBLIC SUPPORT.
I CULTURAL BASE FOR THE LOVE OF
THIS INCREDIBLE REGION.
THROUGHOUT HER CAREER SHE WAS A
TIRELESS ACTIVISTS FOR OPEN
SPACE AND WILDLIFE AND HABITAT
PRESERVATION.
CLEAN WATER AND ENDANGERED
SPECIES PROTECTIONS.
SHE MOST RECENTLY SERVED AS
DIRECTOR OF OUR RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICT OUT IN THE
SANTA MONICA MOUNTAINS.
REPRESENT THE VERY BEST OF OUR
COMMUNITY.
SOMEBODY CARE DEEPLY ABOUT THE
NATURAL WORLD AROUND US AND SHE
FOUGHT WITH EVERY.
PART OF HER BEING TO PROTECT.
SHE IS SURVIVED BY HER EX
HUSBAND JEWEL.
HER SONS NO AND JERRY.
HER THREE GRANDCHILDREN MAISIE
PENNY AND RAFAEL.
HER ZEAL AND DEDICATION TO OUR
COMMUNITY BUT WILL BE MISSED.
AND TODAY I RESPECTFULLY ASK
THAT WE ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF
MARY ELLEN STROKES.
THANK YOU SENATOR STERN AND IF
YOU WOULD PLEASE BRING.
HER NAME FORWARD AND EXTEND
CONDOLENCES TO THE STROKED
FAMILY OF SO WE CAN PROPERLY
ACKNOWLEDGE AND AND RESPECT HER
SERVICE AND CONTRIBUTION AND AT
THIS POINT TO ASSIST IN A
JOINING IN HER MEMORY.
OUR FINAL JOURNEY IN MEMORY
SENATOR ARCH A LETTER.
AND THEN COLLEAGUES WE WILL BE
GOING BACK TO OUR DAILY FILE
CENTER ARCHULETA.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT. TO
THE ATTORNEYS IN THE AUDIENCE MY
COLLEAGUES.
AND TO YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
WOULD LIKE YOU.
TO PAY VERY VERY CLOSE ATTENTION.
BECAUSE IT TOUCHES YOU I'M SURE
AS IT TOUCHES ME.
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS I RISE
TODAY TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF
ONE OF MY CONSTITUENTS MARY
VIRGINIA ROSCOE.
WHO IN?
NINETEEN SIXTY TWO BECAME THE
FIRST LATINA ADMITTED TO THE
CALIFORNIA BAR. NINETEEN SIXTY
TWO THE FIRST LATINA ADMITTED TO
THE CALIFORNIA BAR.
MERRY THE DAUGHTER MEXICAN ON
IMMIGRANTS WOULD BORN IN
WHITTIER CALIFORNIA IN SEPTEMBER.
NINETEEN TWENTY EIGHT TO PUBLIC
OR OROZCO AND MARIA FIGARO RUSKO.
AS A TOP STUDENT IN WITH YOUR
HIGH SCHOOL CLASS OF NINETEEN
FORTY SIX MERRY WAS SELECTED TO
TRAIN AS A LEGAL SECRETARY.
IN A LAW FIRM.
WHILE STILL IN HIGH SCHOOL.
SHE HAD AN AMBITION TO ONE DAY
BE AN ATTORNEY.
HER EXPERIENCE IN THE LAW FIRM
INSPIRED BARRY TO BECOME A LOW
ON A LAWYER.
HER DREAM COME TRUE.
WHILE WORKING TO SUPPORT HER
PARENTS SHOULD MAY GRADUATED
FROM LOS ANGELES STATE COLLEGE
IN.
NINETEEN FIFTY EIGHT WITH THE
GREASE AND PSYCHOLOGY AND
SOCIOLOGY.
MURRAY WHO WAS ONE OF FIVE WOMEN.
IN HER CLASS AT LOYOLA LAW
SCHOOL.
SHE GRADUATED IN NINETEEN SIXTY
ONE AS THE ONLY WOMAN IN HER
CLASS.
AND THE FIRST LATINA GRADUATE.
AFTER SHE WAS ADMITTED TO THE
BAR.
THE CALIFORNIA STATE BAR.
IN THE SPRING OF NINETEEN SIXTY
TWO SHE WAS SURPRISED TO LEARN.
THAT SHE TRULY WAS THE FIRST
LATINA LICENSE TO PRACTICE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THE NINETY SIXTY TWO MERRY
OPENED HER OWN LAW OFFICE IN
MONTEBELLO SERVING THE SPANISH
SPEAKING COMMUNITY.
LATER.
LATER SERVING -- AS A LEADER IN
THE COMMUNITY AND AND CONTINUED
TO PRACTICE LAW AND SHE OPENED.
HER A LAW OFFICE IN IN EAST LOS
ANGELES AND BUSY ATLANTIC
BOULEVARD.
YOUR CONSTITUENTS IN I'M SORRY
HER HER -- COLLEAGUES AND
FRIENDS AND FAMILY CAN ALWAYS
FINDER WITH THEIR DOOR DOOR'S
ALWAYS OPEN IN NINETY SIX NINE
HER TWIN BROTHER HECTOR JOINED
HER IN THE LAW PRACTICE.
MERRY WAS A CO FOUNDER AND
OFFICER OF THE MEXICAN AMERICAN
BAR ASSOCIATION.
LATINO LAWYERS BAR ASSOCIATION
AND THE MONTEBELLO EAST LOS
ANGELES BAR ASSOCIATION.
SHE RETIRED.
FROM PRACTICING LAW IN NINETEEN
NINETY FIVE DESPITE HER
CONSIDERABLE ABILITIES SHE ALSO
FACE DISCRIMINATION BOTH AS A
WOMAN.
AND AS A MEXICAN AMERICAN.
AS A YOUNG ATTORNEY.
WELL MARY WAS SITTING AND
WAITING IN THE COURT ROOM.
A BAILIFF CAME OVER TO HER AND
ESCORTED HER OUT.
READY TO TAKE HER TO THE
COURTHOUSE JAIL.
SHE PROTESTED AND SAID WAIT.
I AM AN ATTORNEY.
THE BAILIFF DID NOT BELIEVE SHE
WAS AN ATTORNEY.
AND THEY WERE BOTH EMBARRASSED
OF THE INCIDENT.
MERRY PASSED AWAY.
SURROUNDED BY HER FAMILY ON JUNE
FIFTH OF THIS YEAR.
SHE IS SURVIVED BY HER SISTER
EMMA HER BROTHER WILLIAM.
HER EIGHT NIECES FOUR NEPHEWS
SEVEN GREAT GRAND NEPHEWS AND
NIECES.
MERRY VIRGINIA OROZCO A PIONEER
IN THE MEXICAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY.
AND FOR THIS REASON I ASKED WE
ADJOURN IN HER MEMORY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR ARCHER LETTER
TO A REAL TRAILBLAZER PLEASE
EXTEND OUR CONDOLENCES TO HER
FAMILY.
WITH THAT COLLEAGUES I JUST WANT --
TO GIVE A SHOT ARE WE HAVE HERE
THE REDWOOD ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
FROM FONTANA CALIFORNIA IN THE
GALLERY IF YOU'D RISE AND IF WE
COULD GIVE YOU A NICE WARM
[inaudible]
SENATE WELCOME.
WELCOME TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE.
COLLEAGUES WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
BACK TO OUR DAILY FILE.
AND START WITH ASSEMBLY MESSAGES.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
MATTER PRESIDENT I'M DIRECTION
FORMER ON THE BODY THAT THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDED AND ON THIS DAY
PASSED AS AMENDED.
SENATE BILL EIGHTY EIGHTY ONE
AND SENATE BILL NINETY
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST OR ON A
BODY TO CONCURRENT SENTIMENTS.
THE DATSUN WILSON SHE COOKED
CHIEF CLERK OF THE ASSEMBLY.
BILLS ORDERS UNFINISHED BUSINESS.
THANK YOU MISTER SECRETARY AT
THIS POINT COLLEAGUES WE ARE
GOING TO GO TO THE FIRST
SUPPLEMENTAL FILE.
AND WE'RE GOING TO START WITH
FILE ITEM OF ONE TWELVE WE ARE
BACK ON THE DAILY FILE OUR FIRST
SUPPLEMENTAL FILE.
FILE ITEM ONE TWELVE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL EIGHTY BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUT IN FISCAL
REVIEW AN ECHOING HUMAN SERVICES
AND MAKING APPROPRIATIONS FOR TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL
RELATED BUDGET.
SENATOR MITCHELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES -- SENATE
BILL EIGHTY IS THE HUMAN
SERVICES BUDGET TRAILER BILL.
THE BILL WILL DO THE FOLLOWING
VERY IMPORTANT THINGS THAT
EIGHT PAYMENT BEGINNING OCTOBER
FIRST OF THIS YEAR.
SO THAT GRANTS FOR HOUSEHOLDS OF
ONE ARE NO LESS THAN 50% OF THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL.
THIS CONTINUES THE LEGISLATURE'S
COMMITMENT TO END CHILDHOOD DEEP
POVERTY IN OUR STATE.
AT A MEN'S THE CAL WORK STAGE
ONE CHILD CARE PROGRAM TO
PROVIDE FULL TIME CONTINUOUS
CHILD CARE THE FAMILIES IN STAGE
ONE FOR TWELVE MONTHS OR UNTIL
THE FAMILIES ARE TRANSFERRED.
THE STAGE TO IT INCREASES THE
CAL WORKS ASSET LIMIT TO TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND THE MOTOR
VEHICLE EXEMPTION A TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TIES
INFLATION FACTORS TO THESE
LIMITS.
IT CREATES A GRANT PROGRAM TO
IMPLEMENT A NO WRONG DOOR SYSTEM
THAT WOULD ENABLE CONSUMERS TO
ACCESS ALL LONG TERM SERVICES
AND SUPPORTS.
HE WON COORDINATED NETWORK.
SUBJECTS COUNTIES TO FINANCIAL
PENALTIES WHEN AGREEMENTS ON
WAGE INCREASES WITH HI JEFF THIS
SERVICE ROVIDERS CANNOT BE
REACHED FOLLOWING A FACT FINDING
PROCESS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR HI
VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER MITCHELL
DEBATER DISCUSSION. FOR ANY
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN.
HI ARCHIE LETTER.
AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
[inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
I FORGES [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
HI CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
DOLLY [inaudible]
DODD.
HI THERE ALSO.
I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER.
AYE GONZALEZ [inaudible]
BY GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
I HILL.
AYE HUESO.
I TITLE [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
BY JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
BY MCGUIRE.
HI MITCHELL HI BY.
MONEY.
I'M MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
WELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH.
I RUBIO.
AYE SKINNER.
AYE STERN [inaudible]
BY STONE [inaudible]
NO NUMBER.
I LIKE HAS HE I WIENER.
AYE WILK.
HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
GORGEOUS NO [inaudible]
CHANGE [inaudible]
DALLY [inaudible]
GROVE [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO.
OUR EYES THIRTY KNOWS SIX
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM.
ONE THIRTEEN MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL EIGHTY ONE BY THE
COMEDIAN BUT IN FISCAL REVIEW AN
ACT RELATING TO DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES AND MAKE IN PREPARATION
FOR TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY
BILL RELATE TO THE BUDGET.
SENATOR MITCHELL THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES WE'RE GONNA
TRANSITION FROM INDIAN CHILDHOOD
DEEP POVERTY. TO DISCUSSIONS
AROUND THE DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES -- BUDGET TRAILER BILL.
THIS BILL REQUIRES THE
DEPARTMENT TO IDENTIFY KEY
INDICATORS IN CONJUNCTION WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO TRACK THE
REGIONAL CENTER DELIVERY OF
SERVICES.
AND TO REPORT THAT INFORMATION
TO THIS BODY.
AND ALLOW FOR RATE INCREASES FOR
SPECIFIED SERVICES CONTINGENT
UPON APPROVAL OF FEDERAL FUNDING
AND ALLOWS FOR SUSPENSION OF
THOSE RATE INCREASES ON DECEMBER.
THIRTY ONE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
UNLESS SPECIFIED CONDITIONS ARE
MET.
CHOIRS THE DEPARTMENT TO CONDUCT
STAKEHOLDER WORK GROUPS TO
DISCUSS SYSTEM AND FISCAL
REFORMS AND TO REPORT THE
FINDINGS OF THOSE DISCUSSIONS
DURING THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BUDGET PROCESS.
IT REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT TO
POST RESPONSES TO DEPARTMENT
RATE STUDY.
AND ANY APPROPRIATE AND
NECESSARY CHANGES TO THE RATE
MODELS CONTAINED IN THE STUDY BY
OCTOBER FIRST OF THIS YEAR.
IT REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT TO
SUBMIT AN UPDATE OF ITS SAFETY
NET PLAN DEVELOPED IN
CONSULTATION WITH STAKEHOLDERS.
ON OR BEFORE JANUARY TEN TWENTY
TWENTY I ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM SENATOR NIELSEN.
BUT IN PRESENT LADIES JOAN THE
SENATE I KNEW VERY LITTLE ABOUT
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
SOME BUT VERY LITTLE THOUGH I
WAS ELECTED TO THE SENATE BECAME
THE SENATOR [inaudible]
FOR THE THE NUMBER STATE
HOSPITAL.
IN CINEMA COUNTY.
A DV INSTITUTION.
AND WAS QUITE A SHOCK FOR MEDIA.
TOUR THOSE WORDS.
SEE THE CONDITION OF THE
INDIVIDUALS THERE IN.
THE GET TO KNOW THE FAMILIES.
THE ANXIETIES THAT THEY WENT
THROUGH.
IN LATER YEARS BEGAN TO DEAL
WITH THE ISSUE A LOT MORE.
RESPONSIBLY AS AS SENATOR.
AND THE SUPPORTER [inaudible]
IN.
I REALIZED THAT.
VERY OFTEN THOSE INDIVIDUALS.
THAT PARTICULAR SECTOR HEALTH
CARE.
ARE NOT PAID THE MOST ATTENTION.
TO I DON'T WANNA SAY NEGLECTED.
BUT DESERVING OF MORE ATTENTION
THAN THEY GET.
AND WE IN THE SENATE CAUCUS
REPUBLICAN CAUCUS HAVE MADE A
HIGH PRIORITY.
OVER THE YEARS [inaudible]
THE SEEK [inaudible]
BETTER FUNDING. FOR THIS
CONSTITUENCY.
THAT IS BEING ACHIEVED IN THIS
BUDGET.
WITH SOME CHANGES THAT WILL
ENSURE [inaudible]
GREATER ACCOUNTABILITY.
OPPORTUNITY FOR PARTICIPATION.
THE FAMILIES AND LOVED ONES.
AND I DO BELIEVE [inaudible]
BETTER CARE. FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WITH THE
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES I
REGION I VOTE [inaudible]
SENATOR PAN -- MATTER PRESENT
CENTERS I TO URGE AN AYE VOTE ON
THIS THREE IMPORTANT TRAILER
BILL.
AND WOULD APPRECIATE -- THE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT -- FOR DD
COMMUNITY I WOULD MAKE NOTE THAT --
SOME OF US WERE HERE DURING THE
RECESSION -- WHEN -- WE HAD TO
MAKE A CUTS -- TO A WIDE VARIETY
OF VERY IMPORTANT PROGRAMS
INCLUDING TO THE D. D..
OUR COMMUNITY AND SINCE THEN WE
HAVE WORKED HARD. TO TRY.
TO ADDRESS THAT -- I WOULD TAKE
NOTES THAT ALSO -- THAT.
IN ORDER TO PREVENT THAT FROM
HAPPENING IN THE FUTURE.
IN ORDER PREVENT THAT FROM HAVE
YOU FUTURE WE ALSO HAVE AS PART
OF THIS BUDGET -- WE ARE
MAINTAINED WE ARE PUTTING IN
RESERVES -- TO TRY TO TO SURE WE
CAN RIDE OUT THE NEXT --
ECONOMIC DOWNTURN WITHOUT HAVING
TO MAKE DRASTIC CUTS TO THESE
SERVICES.
BUT I ALSO WANT TO MAKE NOTE
THAT IS -- WERE -- TALK ABOUT
PARTICULAR TRAILER BILL THAT
FIRST OF ALL TO ACTUALLY OF
THANK THE GOVERNOR -- FOR
ACTUALLY PUTTING IN INITIALLY
HIS INITIAL PROPOSAL -- OF FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION.
THE INCREASE -- FOR THE DD
COMMUNITY AND THE BUDGET ITEMS A
SO THERE'S A FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION INITIAL INCREASE AND
FUNDS.
SOME OF IT IS IT IS DUE -- TO
GREATER CASELOAD BUT I MEAN IS
FOUR HUNDRED MILLION THAT'S NOT
SMALL AMOUNT OF MNEY -- THAT IT
WAS BEING PUT AND NOW I KNOW
THAT WHEN WE HEARD THIS ISSUE
AND BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE ON
HEALTH HUMAN SERVICES WE SAID
WELL.
WE APPRECIATE THAT -- YOU KNOW
THAT'S A THAT'S A GOOD THAT STAT
SAYS SUBSTANTIAL SUM OF MONEY
BUT WE NEED TO DO MORE -- RATE
STUDY WAS DONE SHOWING THAT --
EVEN WITH THAT INCREASE WE ARE --
STILL BEHIND IN FACT I HAVE
STATED IN A BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
THAT -- WE WILL BE HOLDING A
FUTURE HEARINGS -- TO TO EXAMINE
THE RATE INCREASE AT THE RATE
STUDY AND ENSURE WE HOLD THE
ADMINISTRATION ACCOUNTABLE TO
ADDRESSING THE RATES -- THE
FINDINGS OF THE RATE STUDY AND
TO ENSURE ACCESS FOR THE
COMMUNITY.
BUT I AM PLEASED TO SAY THAT WE
HAVE ALSO -- THE LEGISLATURE'S
BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN THE GOSHEN
WITH THE GOVERNOR -- TO HAVE AN
INCREASE BYOND WHAT THE
GOVERNOR INITIALLY PROPOSED AND
SO THAT WE ARE GOING TO BE ABLE
TO RAISE RATES -- FOR A
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES AND I
THINK WE NEED TO RECOGNIZE THAT --
AND TWELVE AT THE SAME TIME --
PROTECTING THE RESERVES WE NEED
TO WRITE OUT A DOWNTURN SO WE
DON'T SEE A SITUATION WHERE WE
FIND AND THEN WE LITERALLY RUN
OUT OF MONEY AND THEN WE COULD.
HAVE TO MAKE REALLY DRASTIC CUTS
SO THERE'S CERTAINLY MORE WORK
TO DO -- IN IN THIS AREA BUT I
THINK WE NEED TO RECOGNIZE THAT --
WE ARE MAKING A VERY IMPORTANT
STEPS FORWARD THIS YEAR WE'VE
MADE THEM IN PREVIOUS YEARS AS
WELL.
DO WE NEED TO MAKE MORE.
SURE YES WE NEED TO DO THAT BUT
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT STEP
FORWARD AND I URGE AND I'VE IT
THANK YOU [inaudible]
SENATOR GROWTH.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I TO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL --
IT IS I'LL LIKE ICE OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM SACRAMENTO SAID --
NOT WHERE WE ALL WANTED TO BE WE
REQUESTED EIGHT HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS AND EVEN WHEN THE RATE
STUDY SAID THAT WE NEEDED A ONE
POINT TWO BILLION DOLLAR
INCREASE IN THIS PARTICULAR
COMMUNITY. TO ORDER TO MEET THE
NEEDS THAT AND THAT THIS
COMMUNITY HAS.
I REALIZE THAT -- GOVERNMENT
NEVER -- OPERATES VERY SWIFTLY
AND I KNOW WE HAVE TO HAVE A
STARTING POINT SO I APPLAUD THE
GOVERNOR FOR HIS FOREIGNER
MILLION DOLLAR INCREASE.
AND THE MATCHING FUNDS THAT WE
WILL GET FROM THE PRESIDENT AND
THE ADMINISTRATION TO INCREASE
IT TO INCREASE -- DOLLAR AMOUNTS
TO FIND THIS BY THE COMMUNITY.
I DO WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT
THERE ARE TWELVE SERVICE CODES
THAT WILL NOT BE FUNDED IN OUR
DD COMMUNITY SO THOSE OF US THAT
ARE VERY ENGAGE WITH OUR
COMMUNITY -- IN OUR DISTRICTS
THIS PARTICULAR COMMUNITY ARE
DISTRICTS YOU WILL HEAR
COMPLAINTS AND SOME ISSUES THAT.
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES WILL NOT
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE WORK PROGRAMS
SO THESE INDIVIDUALS THAT TOOK
PRIDE IN HAVING A JOB AND GOING
TO WORK EVERY DAY AT A REGIONAL
CENTER PROGRAM WILL NO LONGER BE
FUNDED AND THESE PROGRAMS COULD
BE WITHOUT -- WITHOUT THE
FUNDING OF BE CLOSED DOWN.
I KNOW THAT THAT IS THE CASE --
FOR MY DISTRICT AND THE
SURROUNDING AREAS THAT THESE
FUNDING FUNDING THESE PROGRAMS
AND ARE NOT SENDING THESE
PROGRAMS WILL BECAUSE THESE
PROGRAMS TO BE SHUT DOWN.
AND WHEN I THINK OF GARRETT OF A
VERY VERY -- DOW AND INTO
INDIVIDUAL THE SEVERE DOWN
SYNDROME HE GOES TO WORK EVERY
DAY WITH HIS LUNCH BOX LIKE HIS
PARENTS OR HIS UNCLE AND HE'S
NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO DO THAT
ANYMORE BECAUSE THIS PROGRAM
WILL BE FUNDED.
IT'S PRETTY DEVASTATING SO I
APPLIED -- THE BUDGET CHAIR I
KNOW SHE HAS A HEART FOR THIS I
SERVED WITH HER IN THE ASSEMBLY
ON BUDGET SUB.
ONE AND I'M HUMAN SERVICES AND I
KNOW THAT.
I WOULD HOPE THAT SHE WOULD
CONTINUE TO WORK HARD TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE GET THE FUNDING
THAT WE NEED SO THAT THESE WORK
PROGRAMS THE OTHER TWELVE
CATEGORIES CAN BE FUNDED SO THIS
COMMUNITY.
WILL STILL HAVE THE RESOURCES
THAT THEY NEED TO BE ABLE TO TO
HAVE THESE WORK PROGRAMS AND
ENGAGE IN REAL LIFE --
ACTIVITIES THAT CREATE VALUE FOR
THEM -- WE DON'T WANT TO JUST
SIT AT HOME LOOKING OUT A WINDOW.
THIS ACTUALLY CREATES VALUE FOR
THEM TO HAVE A WORK PROGRAM THAT
THEY GO.
TO THESE ARE INDIVIDUALS WITH
HIGH UNEMPLOYMENT RATES IN
SEVERAL DISTRICTS LIKE AT MY
FRIEND DID -- MR GARCIA ON THE
ASSEMBLY SITE IS ONE OF THE
HIGHEST UNEMPLOYMENT RATES IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND THESE INDIVIDUALS CAN'T
COMPETE IN AN OPEN JOB MARKET
WITH INDIVIDUALS THAT DON'T HAVE
A DISABILITY I KNOW SOME PEOPLE
CAN BUT THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE
THAT CAN'T IN THESE WORK
PROGRAMS ARE VALUABLE.
AND IT IS VERY VERY IMPORTANT
THAT WE CONTINUE TO WORK TO MAKE
SURE THAT THESE TWELVE CODES
THAT ARE NOT FUNDED IN THIS BILL
CONTINUE TO BE FUNDED BUT LIKE I
SAID.
WE NEED TO START SOMEPLACE AND I
APPLIED THE GOVERNOR AND THE
BUDGET CHAIR FOR MAKING SURE WE
AT LEAST START SOME PLACE THANK
YOU [inaudible]
SENATOR BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS -- I SUPPORT THIS --
BUDGET TRAILER BILL I REALIZE
THIS IS THE FIRST STEP IN A
JOURNEY WE'RE GOING TO TAKE --
HEART A HARD JOURNEY BECAUSE WE
ARE DATING WITH AN INCREASED
LEVEL.
OF OUR PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA THAT
HAVE DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
IT'S THE POPULATION IS RISING.
AND I THINK THAT -- IT'S BEEN
DIFFICULT OVER THE YEARS.
BECAUSE WE NEEDED TO HAVE THE
FUNDS. TO FIND IT IT WAS IT
WASN'T THAT THERE WAS NOT THE
WILL TO FUND IT.
THERE WAS A NEED TO FIND A WAY
TO FUND IT.
AND FOR US I AM VERY PROUD THAT
WE WERE ABLE TO COME UP WITH THE
FUNDS.
THE FUNDS THAT WERE NECESSARY.
TO FIND THE HEALTH CARE PROGRAM.
AND THE DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES PROGRAM -- WAS A
COURAGEOUS ACT ON THE PART.
OF THE LEGISLATURE'S THAT VOTED
FOR THAT
AND CREATED A OPPORTUNITY THERE
OPEN THE DOORS TO FUND THE
PROGRAMS FOR DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES -- THESE PROGRAMS
ARE VERY IMPORTANT.
LIFESAVING.
LIFE ALTERING PROGRAMS WITHOUT
THESE PROGRAMS -- WE ARE NOT
TAKING CARE OF PEOPLE.
THAT PROBABLY.
CAN'T TAKE CARE OF THEMSELVES --
I WOULD I WANT TO POINT OUT THAT
IS -- FAMILY MEMBER -- OF A
FAMILY THAT HOUSE SOMEBODY HAS
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
THERE ARE OTHER THERE ARE A LOT
OF PEOPLE THAT HAVE DEVELOPMENT
DISABILITIES THAT.
REALLY HAVE NO OTHER PERSON.
IN THEIR LIVES.
OTHER THAN THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
PAID.
BY THIS FUN FROM THIS PROGRAM.
TO TAKE CARE OF THEM AND THEIR
RELATIONSHIPS WITH HUMAN BEINGS
ARE THESE PEOPLE THAT ARE LOW
PAID.
THAT OFTEN TIMES ARE NOT ABLE TO
AFFORD.
IN THEIR LIVES. TO HAVE
[inaudible]
THE THE LOW WAGES.
TAKING CARE OF PEOPLE WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
THIS IS SOUNDING HOW LOW THE
WAGES ARE.
AND I APPLAUD THE GOVERNOR. FOR
A RECOGNIZING THIS BY SUPPORTING.
THE RATE STUDY.
I VIEW THE RATE STUDY AS A TWO
THIRDS DON.
AT A ONE THIRD TO GO.
WE NEED TO HAVE WORK DONE ON
THIS OVER THE NEXT YEAR.
SO THAT.
PEOPLE THAT ARE MAKING FIFTEEN
DOLLARS AN HOUR TAKING CARE
PEOPLE.
IN SAN JOSE AND OTHER HIGH COST
AREAS.
ARE PAID MUCH MORE AND RECOGNIZE
FOR TAKING CARE.
OF THOSE THAT CAN'T TAKE CARE OF
THEMSELVES WITHOUT FAMILY
MEMBERS.
SO FOR ME FOR ME -- THE JOB IS
NOT FINISHED THE ROAD THE ROAD A
REMAINS TO BE WALKED.
AND WE HAVE TO FOLLOW THAT ROAD.
WE HAVE TO FOLLOW THAT ROAD
BECAUSE IF WE DON'T WE'LL HAVE
PEOPLE.
THAT I SEE ON THE STREETS.
THAT ARE DEVELOPING DISABLED
THAT ACTUALLY ARE HOMELESS.
BECAUSE THERE ARE LACKING
SUPPORT.
AND MAYBE HAVING MENTAL HEALTH
PROBLEMS AS WELL.
AS HAVING DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES ABOUT 20%.
HAVE THAT SITUATION.
SO I APPLAUD THE GOVERNOR I
APPLAUD THE BUDGET COMMITTEE AND
THE THE THE ADVOCATES.
AND I WON CALL OUT MY SEC MATE
FROM VENTURA.
HIS STRONG ADVOCACY -- HE SHOWED
UP WHEN THEY NEEDED TO SHOW UP
AND I APPRECIATED THAT OUT SO.
SO AS A FAMILY MEMBER.
OUR REGION I VOTE.
AND WE HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO DO
LET'S ALL WORK TOGETHER TO MAKE
SURE.
THAT THE FUNDING THE THE WAY OF
FUNDING.
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES IS
CONTINUED.
AND THANK YOU TO THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
THE SENATOR FROM VENTURA SENATOR
STERN THE FLOOR IS YOURS JUST A
LITTLE EAST BUT I APPRECIATE
MADAM CHAIR AND TO MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN JOSE -- AND MY
COLLEAGUE FROM BAKERSFIELD -- I
WON'T BE LONG WITH THIS.
BUT I'M GLAD WE'RE SPENDING TIME
ON THIS ISSUE [inaudible]
BECAUSE THESE PEOPLE
WHO ARE EQUAL TO ALL OF US LIVE
IN THE SHADOWS OF SOCIETY ALL
TOO OFTEN AND IF WE WERE TO
STAND UP FOR THEM?
THERE'D BE NO ONE TO STAND UP
FOR THEM.
THIS IS A LONELY ISSUE.
AND THESE ARE.
CHALLENGING LIVES AND JOBS THAT
DON'T PAY ENOUGH THAT FORCED
PEOPLE INTO POVERTY WE ARE
CHIPPING AWAY AT THAT CHALLENGE
WE HAVE NOT YET FULFILLED FULLY
THE PROMISE OF THE LANHAM ACT.
BUT WE ARE MAKING AN INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT DOWN PAYMENT TODAY SO
I THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM SANGER.
FOR STEPPING UP.
OUR BUDGET CHAIR MADAM CHAIR
THANK YOU FOR SPEAKING FOR THOSE
WHO DON'T HAVE A VOICE TODAY
THESE ARE PEOPLE FROM ALL WALKS
OF LIFE ALL INCOMES RACES
GENDERS BACKGROUNDS.
THIS IS IMPORTANT THEIR PROGRESS
SO. TO MANY MORE MANY MORE.
RESPECTFULLY ALL DRIVE A THE I'M
SORRY ALL DEBATE HAVING CEASED
[inaudible]
MADAM.
SENATOR FROM LOS ANGELES YOU MAY
CLOSE THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- I'D
LIKE TO CLARIFY THAT THAT THIS
TRAILER BILL DOES MORE.
THEN ADJUSTS RIGHT SINCE SO I
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE ARE
CLEAR ABOUT THE BREATH OF POLICY
CHANGES.
ON THAT THIS BILL INCLUDES.
YOU KNOW THE DEVELOPMENTAL LEAD
DISOBEY DISABLED COMMUNITY IS
NOT A MONOLITHIC GROUP OR
COMMUNITY.
NOR ARE THE SERVICES THAT THEY
REQUIRE THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA PROVIDES.
UM THIS IS A COMMUNITY THAT
NEEDS.
A SPECTRUM OF SERVICES
EVERYTHING FROM ASSISTANCE ON
THE WORK SITE. TO THOSE WHO
REQUIRE ASSISTANCE IN THEIR
DAILY GROOMING AND DAVE LIVING
[inaudible]
pSTRATEGY THAT WE'VE ENGAGED IN
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS IN
PAYING ATTENTION.
AND PROVIDING INCREMENTAL
IMPROVEMENTS AND INCREASES TO
THOSE SERVICES REFLECTS THAT
DIVERSITY OF SERVICES.
I WANT TO PROVIDE ONE POINT OF
CLARIFICATION.
WE'VE NOT MADE ANY REDUCTIONS
SIGNIFICANTLY THE BASELINE
SERVICES.
THIS TRAILER BILL REFLECTS
AUGMENTATIONS THAT WE WERE ABLE
TO DO.
AND SO WHILE WE FULLY UNDERSTAND
THAT IT'S GETTING HARDER AND
HARDER TO AFFORD TO PROVIDE ME
pTHE SERVICES.
BECAUSE THE REIMBURSEMENT RATE
IS SO LOW.
THERE'S NOTHING IN THIS.
TRAILER BILL THAT WILL ELIMINATE
EXISTING SERVICE IF.
WE'RE CLEAR THERE'S WORK TO BE
DONE TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL.
BOATS RICE BUT THERE'S NOTHING
IN THIS TRAILER BILL THAT
ELIMINATES A SERVICE.
THERE WAS ELOQUENT TESTIMONY IN
THE BUDGET COMMITTEE YESTERDAY.
IT REMINDED ME OF THE TOUGH
VOTES AND DECISIONS WE HAD TO
MAKE A WE ELIMINATE WE DID
ELIMINATE FUNDING TO THE EARLY
START PROGRAM [inaudible]
WHICH PREVENT IT THE STATE'S
ABILITY TO FUND.
EARLY INTERVENTION.
AND EARLY DIAGNOSIS FOR MANY DE
DE [inaudible]
ISSUES.
CHILDREN ON THE SPECTRUM.
WE WERE ABLE TO REFUND THAT
PROGRAM A NUMBER OF YEARS AGO.
AND WE WERE REMINDED THAT THIS
TRAILER BILL SHOULD AND WE MUST
DO MORE IN FUTURE YEARS FOR THE
ZERO TO THREE IN THE DD
COMMUNITY.
AND SO AS MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
SAID THERE'S WORK MORE WORK TO
BE DONE WE'RE ALL CLEAR ABOUT
THAT.
BUT COLLEAGUES WE HAVE COME SO
FAR FROM WHERE WE WERE DURING
THE GREAT RECESSION.
AND SO WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE ADVOCATES THE PARENTS.
THE CLIENT TO THE DD SERVICES
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
TO MAKE SURE.
THAT THE LAND COMMENDED THE
ELEMENTAL SERVICES ACT AND ITS
VISION AND MISSION CONTINUES TO
BE A PALED IN HONORED AS WE GO
FORWARD.
IN OUR BUDGETING PROCESS FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA ASKS FOR AN
AYE VOTE IN SB.
EIGHTY ONE DEBATE HAVING SEIZED
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI.
ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS BY BATES.
HI BILL.
I PORGES [inaudible]
I BRADFORD.
BY CABALLERO.
BY CHIANG [inaudible]
HI DOLLY.
I DODD.
BY THE RAZA [inaudible]
I GALGIANI.
BY GLAZER BY GONZALEZ HI
[inaudible]
THE GROWTH.
HI HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
HI OR TITLE HI JACKSON
[inaudible]
BY JONES [inaudible]
HI LEYVA.
TIME.
AYE MITCHELL.
AYE MONNING.
I'M MORE LOCK TIME RAIL
[inaudible]
I NIELSEN.
BY PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
BY RUBIO.
BY SKINNER.
AYE STERN [inaudible]
I STONE [inaudible]
HI NUMBER.
OUR CASKEY I WINNER.
HI WILK.
HI.
ICE FORTY KNOWS ZERO ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
OUR FINAL ITEM UNDER THE
SUPPLEMENTAL FILE IS FILE ITEM.
ONE FOURTEEN MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL NINETY
BY THE COMMITTEE ON BUT IN
FISCAL REVIEW AN ECHOING TO
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES RETIREMENT.
MAKING PROVISION THEREFORE TAKE
AFFECT ME LEAVE THE RELATED BUT
SENATOR MITCHELL.
THANK YOU SB NINE IS THE PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES RETIREMENT TRAILER
BILL THE BILL MAKE SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS TO PAY DOWN THE
STATE'S WALL OF DEBT.
AND HELPS THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
THE DRAFT THEIR PENSION
LIABILITIES.
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL MAKES A
THREE BILLION DOLLARS
SUPPLEMENTAL PENSION PAYMENT TO
PAY DOWN THE STATE'S CALPERS
UNFUNDED LIABILITY.
THIS BILL REDUCES SCHOOL
EMPLOYERS CAL STARS AND CALPERS
CONTRIBUTION RATES AND PROVIDES
FIVE POINT ONE SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS TO REDUCE THE STATE AND
DISTRICT CHAIR OF THE CAL STARS.
UNFUNDED LIABILITY THESE
INVESTMENTS ARE CRITICAL IN
HELPING TO REDUCE THE WALL OF
DEATH AND PROVIDING RELIEF TO
SCHOOL DISTRICTS I ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION SENATOR
MOORE Là.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB.
NINETY WHEN YOU'RE DEEP IN DEBT.
IT IS WISE TO PAY THEM DOWN WHEN
YOU RECEIVE A BONUS FROM WORK OR
ANOTHER WINDFALL LIKE A CASH
GIFT FOR MONETARY GIVE FROM.
A RELATIVE SO IN THE LAST YEAR.
CALIFORNIA'S UNFUNDED ACTUARIAL
ACCRUED LIABILITIES FOR THE
PENSION PLANS ON OUR BALANCE
SHEET ROSE BY ELEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS.
THEREFORE DEDICATING THREE
BILLION MORE.
TOWARDS CALPERS IS THE RIGHT
THING TO DO.
WERE FALLING BEHIND BUT I I WISH
THERE FOR THAT.
THE BUDGET DID MORE AS
CALIFORNIA IS FALLING BEHIND.
WITH THIS MASSIVE DEBT.
IT ALSO GIVES AN ASSIST TO THE
CAL STIRS.
BY REDUCING ITS UNFUNDED
ACTUARIAL ACCRUED LIABILITY
[inaudible]
THEREFORE.
REDUCING THE ANNUAL
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE DEFINED
BENEFIT PENSION PLAN BY THE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
THIS -- IS SOMETHING THAT OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS NEED THEY NEED
SOME RELIEF.
AND THIS IS A NICE GESTURE I
WISH THIS BUDGET CONSIDER DOING
SOMETHING SIMILAR. FOR OUR
CITIES AND COUNTIES AS THEY ALSO.
NEED SOME RELIEF.
THE BEST SOLUTION.
IS TO PROVIDE NEW EMPLOYEES WITH
A DEFINED CONTRIBUTION PLAN.
SIMILAR TO THAT OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
BECAUSE GIVING RAISES WITH FOR
EMPLOYEES IN A DEFINED BENEFIT
PLAN IS VERY DIFFICULT THE IN.
FACTIT IS IS BIGGER THAN JUST
THE REYES.
AB NINETY DEALS WITH THE FISCAL
STRAITJACKET AS IT IS.
AND I THANK THE GOVERNOR FOR HIS
INITIATIVE.
BUT WE NEED TO ADDRESS
RETIREMENT SUSTAINABILITY FOR
THE LONG TERM.
WITH THAT I ENCOURAGE AN AYE
VOTE.
ON AB NINETY ENCOURAGE US ALL TO
LOOK AT THE FUTURE TO SEE WHAT
WE CAN DO TO REDUCE OUR UNFUNDED
LIABILITIES THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM SEEING
AND HEARING NONE IN THE SENATORS
MICROPHONE IS DOWN.
WE WILL SIMPLY ASK MISTER
SECRETARY TO CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
HI BILL [inaudible]
BY BURGESS [inaudible]
BY BRADFORD.
BY COMING YET -- BY CHAIN.
BY DELHI.
BY DODD.
HI THERE ALSO [inaudible]
BY GALGIANI.
BY GLAZER.
BY GONZALEZ HI.
GROWTH.
I HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL [inaudible]
BY HUESO.
HI -- TITLE.
I JACKSON HI BY JONES
[inaudible]
BY LEYVA.
MY MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL.
AYE MONNING.
BY MORE LOCK.
I AM A REAL BY NELSON.
I PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH.
AYE RUBIO.
AYE SKINNER.
I STERN AYE STONE.
BY A BURKE.
BOB WHAT CASSIE I WINNER
[inaudible]
HI WILK.
HI HIGHS FORTY KNOWS ZERO
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
COLLEAGUES WERE GOING TO GO TO
THE CONSENT CALENDAR -- ARE
THERE ANY.
REQUEST TO REMOVE ANY ITEMS FROM
THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
I DO HAVE ONE I WOULD LIKE TO
REMOVE FILE ITEM NUMBER NINETY
FIVE AB.
SIX OH THREE FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR [inaudible]
SO NOTED.
AND NOW COLLEAGUES WE WILL TAKE
UP THE CONSENT.
CALENDAR.
MR SECTOR PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE EIGHTY EIGHT
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
THIRTY ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE NINETY
SEVEN ASSEMBLY BILL THREE TWENTY
SEVEN ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION. EIGHTY EIGHT NINETY
TWO ASSEMBLY BLL TO TWELVE
FIFTEEN THIRTY THREE A FIFTY ONE
TWELVE EIGHTY NINE ASSEMBLY BILL
1-336-205-1530 SEVEN ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION THIRTY
SIXTY TO SIXTY FIVE EIGHTY TWO
AND ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION.
NINETY SIX IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING OUR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL.
SHE NINE EYES FORTY KNOWS ZERO
THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
COLLEAGUES WE HAVE -- COMPLETED
TODAY'S CALENDAR IN IF THERE IS
NO OTHER BUSINESS.
SENATOR ATKINS THE DESK IS CLEAR
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT ON
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU FOR ANOTHER
VERY PRODUCTIVE AND VERY BUSY
WEEK
I KNOW THAT WE HAVE A FEW
REMAINING -- BUDGET TRAILER%
BILL'S GOING INTO MONDAY BUT I
HOPE EACH OF YOU GO HOME AND
HAVE A RELAXING AND GOOD --
WEEKEND WITH FAMILY AND
COMMUNITY WE WILL RECONVENE ON
MONDAY JUNE TWENTY FOURTH AT TWO
PM THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU MADAM PRO TEM THE
SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL
ALL LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS IS
RECEIVED AT THE DESK.
WE RECONVENE MONDAY AT TWO PM